Pons and cortex visual.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Hallo, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier zur 195. Ausgabe. Ja, nachdem in den letzten Folgen die Themen auch wild variierten, dachte ich mir, bleibe ich gleich dabei und steige heute mal auf was ein, was wir hier auch so in der Form auch noch überhaupt nicht hatten. Genau, ich möchte mal ein wenig in den Kopf gucken, in unser aller Hirn und rauskriegen, was denn da eigentlich nun tatsächlich so abgeht. Das habt ihr euch sicherlich ja auch alle schon mal gefragt. Und um da gute Antworten zu finden, begrüße ich John im Studio. John, John Dylan Haynes heißt er eigentlich, ne? Genau. Ist auch so eine britische Abstammung vorzuweisen.
Genau.
Aber genauso wie bei mir merkt man dir das nicht an.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Kryptobriete. Kryptobriete nennt man das? Genau.
Aha. Okay, Kryptobriete, das ist gut. Ja, Hirn ist ein Thema, kann man sagen. Du hast hier eine Professur inne, mit dem klanglich hochwertigen Namen Theorie und Analyse weiträumiger Hirnsignale. Was heißt das denn?
Genau, also das heißt, dass man sich das Gehirn auf einer sehr weiträumigen Ebene anschaut. Das Gehirn kann man sich auf verschiedenen Auflösungsstufen betrachten. Man kann zum einen sich die einzelnen Nervenzellen oder sogar Bestandteile von einzelnen Nervenzellen anschauen. Das nennt man dann zelluläre Neurowissenschaft. Dann organisieren sich, gruppieren sich diese Nervenzellen aber in immer komplexeren Verbänden, wo sie dann bestimmte kognitive Aufgaben erledigen können. Je nachdem, auf welcher Auflösungsstufe man sich befindet, wenn man sich das auf der Ebene von Millionen oder zig Millionen Nervenzellen anschaut, dann befindet man sich bei den weiträumigen Hirnsignalen. Die kann man auch bei Menschen messen. Man kann natürlich bei Menschen sehr schwer eine Elektrode in den Kopf bringen und dann die einzelnen Nervenzellen messen. Aber man kann mithilfe von Elektroenzyphalographie oder Kernspintomographie das Verhalten von größeren Verbänden von Nervenzellen sich anschauen.
Das heißt, es ist mehr der Schritt zurück. Man schaut mehr aufs Ganze als aufs Einzelne.
Genau, man schaut auf das Gesamtmuster der Hirnaktivität, während man mit zellulären Ansätzen, wo man auf der einzelnen Nervenzelle ansetzt, sich eher das Mikroskopische anschaut. Wenn man jetzt wissen möchte, wie organisiert das Gehirn als Ganzes eine bestimmte geistige Leistung, zum Beispiel Erinnern, Planen, Gefühle, Wahrnehmung etc., dann muss man sich schon diese weiträumigen Netzwerke anschauen. Und das ist auch so, das muss man auch ganz klar sagen, ist so ein bisschen die Not zu Tugend gemacht. Bei Menschen kann man halt nicht die einzelnen Nervenzellen gut anschauen. Es gibt ganz seltene Fälle, wo das möglich ist. Aber in der Regel kann man es nicht. Und deswegen ist es halt das Beste, was man bei Menschen machen kann, ist, sich mit einer etwas niedrigeren Auflösung ran zu machen, aber sich dann das Gehirn als Ganzes anzuschauen.
Wenn man so ein bisschen mal in die Vergangenheit einsteigt, wie das Hirn funktioniert, hat ja die Menschen schon immer interessiert. Ganz klar. Aber so richtig die Durchbrüche darüber, was wirklich dort abgeht, sind ja alle noch gar nicht so lange her, oder?
Ja, es gibt eine ganze Historie von Durchbrüchen. Ich würde sagen, eine der großen Durchbrüche war vor ungefähr 100 Jahren, als Leute begonnen haben, das Gehirn systematisch zu kartografieren. Da gibt es dann zum Beispiel die sogenannten Brodmann-Ariale. Da war dann jemand, der hat tatsächlich so richtig zum ersten Mal systematisch sich das gesamte Gehirn angeschaut und hat einfach geguckt, wie die Organisation der Nerven zählen.
Also angeschaut im Sinne von, er hat sich ein Hirn genommen und es dann...
Genau. Er hat es geschnitten, ein Hirn genommen, es geschnitten, es eingefärbt und hat dann einfach geschaut, wie ist die Organisation der Nerven zählen. Und hat dann gefunden, dass es so weiträumige Bereiche gibt, so mehrere Quadratzentimeter, wo die Nervenzellen ganz ähnlich strukturiert sind. Und wenn man dann ein bisschen weitergeht auf der Hirnoberfläche, gibt es dann eine andere Region, die anders strukturiert ist. Und das sind die sogenannten Brodmann-Ariale.
Das war dann der Herr Brodmann, oder?
Genau. Und das sind so eine der großen Errungenschaften, dass man festgestellt hat, dass es in der Anatomie des Gehirns einen Beleg dafür gibt, dass es eine Arbeitsteilung geben muss. Also so verschiedene Bereiche des Gehirns was anderes machen. Das war nämlich immer so eine Diskussion in der Geschichte der Hirnforschung. Es gab die einen, die haben gesagt, das Gehirn ist eher wie so ein Hologramm. Das ist quasi alles an jeder Stelle gespeichert. Wenn man was rausnimmt, dann gibt es eigentlich gar keine großen Defizite. Wenn man an einer einzelnen Stelle ein bisschen durch einen Schaden, durch einen Schlaganfall oder irgendwas, was rausnehmen würde, würde es eigentlich gar nicht so ein großes Problem machen. Das sind so quasi die holistischen Rangehensweisen. Und dann gab es die sogenannten Lokalisationisten, die haben dann die Theorie vertreten, dass einzelne Funktionen ganz klar bestimmten Regionen des Gehirns zuzuordnen sind. Und das kam so eigentlich im 19. Jahrhundert erst so richtig auf, dass man dafür gute Belege hatte, dass es so war.
Aber gab es nicht schon immer so medizinische Fälle, wo, keine Ahnung, jemand sich verletzt hat, eine bestimmte Stelle betroffen wurde und dann setzt er halt diese oder jede Funktion aus, wo man das gut hätte ablesen können?
Aber es waren natürlich Schlaganfälle, sind nicht sehr diffus und mit diesen sehr selektiven Ausfällen war es dann zum ersten Mal möglich zu sagen, ich sage jetzt mal, da fällt zum Beispiel die Sprache aus, die Fähigkeit, Sprache zu verstehen oder die Sprache zu produzieren. Das waren so zwei berühmte Defizite, die man dann ganz klar sehr hochselektiven Ausfällen zuordnen konnte, wobei viele andere Sachen dann erhalten geblieben sind. Also was man immer sucht in solchen Fällen ist, man sucht nicht nach diffusen Schädigungen, wo einfach alles betroffen ist, sondern man sucht immer etwas, wo so ein Glas klar nur eine einzige Funktion ausgefallen ist und alles andere erhalten geblieben ist. Ein anderes Beispiel, ein sehr selektiver Ausfall ist die sogenannte Prosopagnosie, also die Unfähigkeit Gesichter zu erkennen. Und es ist auch ein sehr selektiver Ausfall, das ist ein ganz kleiner Teil des Gehirns betroffen dann, und der halt Gesichter verarbeitet. Und man kann quasi dann alles andere erkennen, man kann Tische, Stühle erkennen, man kann dann Tiere erkennen, aber man kann dann keine Gesichter erkennen und nicht die Person erkennen.
Also man erkennt schon, dass es sich um ein Gesicht handelt, aber diese Unterscheidung nicht mehr, was bei Babys schon so stark ist.
Ja, es kann so verschiedene Ebenen haben, Gesichtserkennung oder das große Problem ist dann die Zuordnung des Individuums, etwas, was für uns in unserem Alltag sehr wichtig ist, dass wir erkennen können, dass es sich um eine bestimmte Person handelt. Das bedeutet, dass man die genaue Konstellation von Merkmalen im Gesicht erkennen muss und zuordnen muss. Es gibt viele Leute, die haben die gleichen Augenfarben, die gleichen Augenbrauen, die gleichen Haare und so weiter. Das kommt also auf die Konstellation an, mit der wir dann ein Gesicht erkennen können. Wir sind ja als Menschen in der Regel auch sehr gut damit. Aber es gibt auch Menschen, die können das nicht. Die können sagen, die müssen sich das erst mühsam konstruieren. Die sagen, die Person ist blond, hat blaue Augen und hat, was ist ich, was ein Schnurrbart. Das muss also, was ist ich, mein Vermieter sein oder sowas.
Und das ist, wo ist das die Stelle?
Die ist im sogenannten Temporallappen. Das ist also ein Teil des Gehirns quasi, wenn man, am besten reden wir einfach nur von oben unten links rechts und vorne hinten, unten im Gehirn. Aber im Bereich des Cortex, also der neuesten Schicht des Gehirns evolutionär gesehen.
Achso, was sich sozusagen als letztes überhaupt in der Evolution herausgebildet hat.
Genau, also der Neocortex, das ist, wenn man auf das Gehirn draufguckt, sieht man eigentlich nur Neocortex erstmal. Das ist also so evolutionsgeschichtlich so das Neueste am Gehirn. Und diese Bereich, wo man Gesichter wahrnimmt, der ist auch diesem Neocortex zuzuordnen. Die meisten höheren Funktionen, von denen, mit denen wir es zu tun haben, in der Hirnforschung, also in der Human-Hirnforschung, sind in der Regel in diesem Neocortex zu verordnen.
Den hat nur der Mensch?
Nein, nein, den haben viele Tiere. Das kann man mit Primaten vergleichen. Da sieht man, dass die meisten Regionen, die ein nicht-menschlicher Primat hat, also z.B. ein Affe, dass wir mit denen sehr viele Hirnregionen teilen.
Also sowohl die Orte, die die ähnliche Funktion haben, als auch die Gesamtanzahl dieser Orte.
Genau, wir nutzen es dann wahrscheinlich anders. Wir haben zwar so, bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen, sehr ähnliche Hirnregionen wie ein Affe, aber wir nutzen es anscheinend ganz anders, weil wir zu viel komplexeren Verhaltensleistungen fähig sind. Wir können komplexe Sprache, wir können Planungsleistungen vollbringen, die Tiere nicht vollbringen können. Unsere Sozialorganisation ist komplexer. Also das sind so Dinge, die Tiere dann nicht können. Aber es scheint nicht so zu sein, dass dafür dann immer ganz neue Hirnregionen erfunden werden müssen, sondern zum Teil ist es wahrscheinlich so, es ist jetzt eine Vermutung, so genau weiß man das nicht, aber dass die bestehenden Hirnregionen vielleicht auch einfach sich ein bisschen weiterentwickeln und dann auch anders genutzt werden zu neuen Dingen.
Das heißt so, was ist uns denn so am ähnlichsten hirntechnisch von den Tieren?
Ja, es kommt drauf an, wofür man sich interessiert. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel für das Sä system interessiert, dann sind uns eben die Affen sehr ähnlich. Und deswegen wird auch sehr viel Forschung, also viel Forschung kann man jetzt nicht gerade sagen, aber sehr viel interessante Forschung wird gemacht mit Affen, weil uns das Affengehirn sehr ähnlich ist. Und natürlich die Menschenaffen sind uns noch ähnlicher. Aber da gibt es meistens ethische Gründe, dass man an denen keine invasiven Hirnforschungsexperimente macht. Das ist also meistens den anderen Affen.
Also Gorillas, Orang-Utanen?
Genau, mit denen macht man das nicht, in der Regel. Aus ethischen Gründen und bei den so genannten Makaken-Affen, da gibt es dann schon invasiv vorgegangen, invasive Experimente gemacht.
Schließt das die Schimpansen mit ein oder aus?
Nein, nein, nein. Die Schimpansen werden nicht invasiv beforscht. Also es kann sein, dass es irgendwo jemand macht, aber die meisten Hirnforscher machen das nicht.
Ist ja schon ein bisschen erstaunlich, wenn man so im Orang-Utan eine Weile zuschaut, wie er so sein Dasein fristet. Ist ja ein bisschen traurig so im Zoo eigentlich, aber die Ähnlichkeiten sind erschlagen und man fragt sich natürlich dann immer so.
Bonobos ist auch ein beliebtes Beispiel, die ausschweifende Sexualverhalten haben. Das ist wirklich auch etwas, wo man sich dann wieder spielen finden kann oder nicht drin wiederfinden kann.
Das heißt, man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass sie auf dieselbe Art denken eigentlich im Prinzip?
Ja, so genau weiß man das nicht. Und man kann das immer nur sehr indirekt erschließen, weil wir beim Menschen, wenn wir es beim Menschen wissen wollen, immer den großen Vorteil haben, dass wir den Menschen fragen können. Wir teilen also die Sprache und können dann so komplizierte Dinge fragen, wie zum Beispiel, was denkst du gerade? Oder hast du darüber nachgedacht? Da können wir so Dinge rausfinden, wie wenn jemand im Auto gefahren ist und sich die ganze Zeit lebhaft unterhalten hat, dass er dann am Zielort ankommt und sagt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich hierher gekommen bin. Ich war also die ganze Zeit so im Gespräch vertieft. Ich habe gar nicht gemerkt, wie ich Auto gefahren bin. Und dann können wir feststellen, dass anscheinend diese Person mehr oder weniger automatisch das Auto gefahren ist die ganze Zeit. Bei Tieren ist das schwieriger. Bei Tieren können wir nicht solche Fragen stellen. Wir müssen also immer indirekt aus dem Verhalten schließen. Das ist dann manchmal auch mit der Interpretation ziemlich schwierig. Und da ist man sich vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer ganz einig, zu welchen Leistungen Tiere fähig sind oder nicht. Das ist auch einfach eine Interpretationsfrage. Also der Hundebesitzer, der jedes Mal, bevor man nach Hause kommt, da steht der Hund schon an der Tür und kratzt an der Tür. Und denkt dann, der Hund hat jetzt irgendeinen sechsten Sinn und hat jetzt erkennen können, dass ich gerade nach Hause komme. Aber ich komme natürlich jeden Tag um 5 Uhr nach Hause und das weiß der Hund auch. Dann mag man dem vielleicht etwas zuschreiben, was gar nicht der Fall ist. Es ist also einfach ein schwieriges Problem, dass man es nicht so genau weiß. Und dass unsere Intuition uns manchmal vielleicht auch in die Irre lenken können, in die Irre führen können, darüber, was Tiere denken können und was sie nicht denken können. Das ist einfach ein schwieriges Thema. Man weiß halt vieles darüber. Der Pavlovsche Hund hat sich wahrscheinlich auf das Essen gefreut, als er gespeichelt hat.
Ja, es wird jetzt am liebsten noch in tausende Jahre Evolution einsteigen. Ich weiß bloß nicht, wie weit uns das weiterbringt. Aber wie lange hat denn der Mensch jetzt dieses Hirn, so wie es heute ist?
Ja, das weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Da müsste man einen Biologen fragen, einen Evolutionsbiologen. Das ist jetzt nicht ein Thema, mit dem ich mich intensiv befasst habe. Aber sicherlich schon ein paarzigtausend Jahre.
Aber trotzdem gibt es nicht so die Vermutung, oder ist das auch eine Erkenntnis, oder stimmt das vielleicht auch gar nicht so, dass der Mensch dann quasi rasant intelligenter geworden ist, in dem Moment, wo sich so seine Lebensumstände deutlich verbessert haben? Also sprichst du Ackeranbau, besseres Essen, mehr Nahrung, lalala.
Genau, da müsste man dann wieder wahrscheinlich einen Anthropologen fragen, oder einen Ethnologen, einen Anthropologen fragen. Die Frage lässt sich schwer beantworten, weil wir wirklich keine Gehirne aus dieser Zeit haben. Man kann jetzt also nicht genau sagen, wie, ob jetzt sich im Laufe der letzten 50.000 Jahre die Hirnstruktur auf eine interessante Art und Weise plötzlich geändert hat. Soweit mir das bekannt ist, wie gesagt, da bin ich jetzt nicht vom Fach, was die Evolutionsbiologie angeht, aber soweit mir das bekannt ist, gibt es da jetzt in den letzten 10.000 Jahren keine großen Sprünge, keine biologischen Sprünge, sodass man sich dann fragen muss, die rasante Entwicklung muss sicherlich eine andere Ursache haben, als dass sich unsere Gehirnstruktur geändert hat. Wahrscheinlich gibt es dann so einen, wie man das so schön nennt, Synergieeffekt, sprich, es gibt also ein positives Zusammenwirken von vielen verschiedenen Faktoren. Und diese verschiedenen Faktoren sind sicherlich, dass die Kultur uns etwas ermöglicht hat, neue, wie soll man sagen, neues Potenzial in unserem Gehirn zu nutzen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass man es einfach rein mit der Hardware des Gehirns erklären kann.
Also im Prinzip die ganzen Kulturtechniken, dass man halt einfach entspannt erlebt, bessere medizinische Versorgung hat etc.
Genau, wir wissen eins, dass selbst wenn sich unser Gehirn dieser Zeit vielleicht nicht großartig verändert hat, so wissen wir doch zumindest, dass es zeigt, dass unser Gehirn zu, wenn man es quasi seiner Eigendynamik überlässt, dass es dann zu sehr einer sehr komplexen Entwicklungsgeschichte fähig ist, die dann die Gesellschaft produziert, die wir heute haben. Das dauert halt eine Weile und das Gehirn ist halt ein Substrat, eine Trägersubstanz für Gedanken, die dann dazu in der Lage ist, dann diese Kulturen hervorzubringen, mit all ihren guten und schlechten Seiten.
Kommen wir nochmal wieder zurück zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo der Herr Bruttmann dann die Lokalisierungstheorie quasi bewiesen hat. Hat er das?
Ja, er hat das gezeigt, dass das Substrat, die Anatomie des Gehirns, quasi erklären kann, warum es so eine Funktionentrennung gibt. So kann man es vielleicht formulieren.
Und war das dann so der Auslöser von mehr Forschung? Also gab es dann schnelle Fortschritte oder tat sich das erstmal wieder?
Ja, es gab in Deutschland, also gerade in Deutschland, im 19. Jahrhundert gab es, schon vor Brotmann, gab es unglaublich viel Hirnforschung. Und man kann fast sagen, dass alle großen Ideen und alle großen Diskussionen damals schon geführt worden sind. Diskussionen über Willensfreiheit, Diskussionen über Bewusstsein und Gehirn. Also wie kann es sein, dass eine, ich sage jetzt mal, materielle Substanz wie das Gehirn, auch wenn sie komplex organisiert ist, sowas hat wie Bewusstsein, Erlebnisse. Wie kann es sein, dass jemand auf einmal Roterlebnisse hat oder Töne hört oder sowas. Wenn wir, sage ich mal, einen Sandhaufen haben, der hat ja auch keine Erlebnisse. Oder einen Computer, da glauben wir auch nicht, dass der Erlebnisse hat. Aber vielleicht glaubt das der eine oder andere. Aber ich habe noch nie gehört, dass jemand sich nicht getraut hat, einen Computer auszuschalten, weil er meint, dass der Computer vielleicht noch Erlebnisse hat und dadurch als Person behandelt werden muss. Und ich habe auch noch nie gehört, dass jemand einen Computer vor Gericht gestellt hat. Insofern gibt es Dinge, die wir als Sachen behandeln. Aber bestimmte Art von materiellen Substanzen, wie zum Beispiel Gehirne, behandeln wir als Personen. Und das ist natürlich eine interessante Sichtweise auf einmal auf Materie, dass wir bestimmte Materie anders behandeln als andere. Und wenn man jetzt noch mal zurückkommt zu dieser Entwicklung, gab es also viele Diskussionen im 19. Jahrhundert. Man muss dann schon sagen, es gab dann sehr viel Forschung im 20. Jahrhundert über zettuläre Grundlagen von vielen Funktionen. Aber wenn man aus meiner Perspektive als jemand, der mich vor allem für das menschliche Gehirn interessiert und für die Gesamtaktivität des Gehirns, ging es dann eigentlich erst wieder so richtig weiter, als man Techniken hatte, mit denen man die menschliche Hirnaktivität aufzeichnen konnte. Und so eine richtige Boom kam dann eigentlich erst in den 80er und 90er Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts.
Welche Techniken waren das, die dann aufkamen?
Ja, also erstmal zu nennen, ist in den 20er Jahren von Herrn Berger aus Jena zu nennen das EEG, Elektro-Enzymphalographie. Man kann sich das im Grunde genommen vorstellen wie so ein Gerät, was die Spannung auf der Kopfhaut misst und damit so auch wiederum indirekt messen kann, was so und wo im Gehirn bestimmte Prozesse gerade ablaufen.
Das sind so diese klassischen Narrenkappen, die man kennt, wo dann viele Kabel rangehen.
Genau, also es sah bei ihm noch damals ziemlich abenteuerlich aus und er hat dann als erster festgestellt, dass es dann diese Hirnwellen gibt, von denen man ja auch immer so gerne spricht. Da gibt es dann die Alpha-Wellen und die Beta-Wellen. Das hat er einfach so beschrieben, weil das erste, was er gefunden hat, waren die Alpha-Wellen. Da waren seine Probanden wahrscheinlich im entspannten Wachzustand, aber in Ruhe. Und dann kriegt man diese Alpha-Wellen und wenn man dann auf einmal anfängt, eine Aufgabe zu rechnen oder irgendwie geistige Aktivität zu beginnen, dann verändert sich das EEG. Und dann sieht man eine andere Art von Wellen, die nennen sich dann Beta-Wellen. Das hat ja einfach so durchnummeriert.
Von was für einem Frequenzbereich reden wir jetzt?
Das ist ungefähr 10 Hertz. Also diese Alpha-Wellen sind 10 Hertz und das ist auch so mit das dominanteste Signal, was man im EEG findet. Und man kann das dann noch verstärken, z.B. wenn man die Augen zumacht, dann gibt es noch viel, viel mehr Alpha-Wellen. Das ist also irgendein Signal, was sehr grob gesprochen mit Entspannung zusammenhängt. Deswegen haben dann in den 60er und 70er Jahren Leute auch versucht, Entspannungstechniken aufzubauen, zu ermöglichen, indem man diese Alpha-Wellen mit Bio-Feedback versucht hat zu boosten. Das heißt also, man hat, man weiß ja nicht normalerweise, wie hoch die Alpha-Wellen gerade sind, ausschlagen. Dann hat man also Geräte gebaut, die sichtbar gemacht haben, wie stark das Alpha gerade ist. Da sieht man z.B. so eine Skala, die dann wie so ein Powermeter an so einem Kassettenrekorder oder so, dann Entspannometer und je höher das Alpha ist, das schlägt das dann immer weiter aus. Und dann hat man Leute also gebeten, dieses Alpha möglichst hoch zu machen.
Sei entspannt.
Sei möglichst entspannt, genau. Und das funktioniert auch. Man kann das tatsächlich trainieren, das Alpha nach oben zu bringen. Ich habe mich da mal vor ein paar Jahren mal ein bisschen eingelesen und mein Eindruck war, dass, ein sehr interessanter Befund, dass man kann trainieren, das Alpha hoch zu regulieren, aber das Problem ist, dass am höchsten ist das Alpha dann, bevor dem Experiment, während der Proband einfach entspannt im Stuhl sitzt und darauf wartet, dass das Experiment losgeht. Das heißt, wenn man sich richtig Mühe gibt, sich zu entspannen, dann kann man ungefähr so entspannt sein, wie wenn man sich einfach entspannt.
Ja, Entspannungsstress.
Genau, genau.
Da gab es ja diese Mind-Machines, das war ja auch mal ganz hip.
Genau, das ist natürlich alles totaler Humbug. Also das ist kompletter Humbug.
Also diese Brillen mit so LEDs drin, die dann so...
Ja, das ist interessant. Es ist wie bei Religion. Man wundert sich manchmal, wie sehr Menschen nach Dingen greifen können, die offensichtlich keine Realitätsbasis haben. Und das ist bei diesen Mind-Machines genauso. Das ist einfach eine Spielerei.
Das ist nachweislich keine Auswirkung sozusagen.
Ja, ich bin mir sicher, dass auch mal jemand ein Experiment gemacht hat und konnte eine Wirkung zeigen. Aber das ist nichts, was eine starke Wirkung haben kann.
Aber das ist bestimmt teuer verkauft worden.
Ja, es gab glaube ich Bausätze. Ich kannte auch mal Leute, die kamen mit so was an. Und sollte man sein Geld lieber anders ausgeben.
Okay, lieber in den Urlaub buchen oder so was.
Genau, dann entspannt man sich besser. Oder mal vielleicht mal in die Sauna gehen.
Ja, entspannt aus, ja. Gut, also das heißt, das Hirn, muss man sich das vorstellen, also wir reden jetzt wirklich von Strömen, von Spannungen, die dort anliegen. Das heißt, das Hirn ist eigentlich so eine Art Batterie, kann man das so sagen. Also wo kommen die Ströme her, wo gehen sie hin? Wenn man die an der Kopfhaut anfassen, abgreifen kann, dann heißt das ja, das ist im Prinzip eine unterschiedliche Verteilung von Stromladungen im Kopf gibt, die die ganze Zeit irgendwie durch die Gegend fließen.
Genau, wir haben also diese Nervenzellen und diese Nervenzellen, die erzeugen genau das, die erzeugen sogenannte Aktionspotenziale. Das heißt, eine Nervenzelle kann man sich vorstellen, wie viele Kabel die reinkommen. Und dann wird eine kleine Entscheidung gefällt und dann gibt es an der anderen Stelle, gibt es etwas, was rausgeht, das was reinkommt, das nennt man Dendriten. Das ist quasi die Eingangsantenne, könnte man so ungefähr formulieren. Und rausgehend von dem Zellkörper geht dann das sogenannte Axon. Das Axon meldet weiter an die nächste Zelle, was die Ausgabe der Berechnung in dieser Nervenzelle ist. Und das sind natürlich alles Prozesse, die mit Spannung verbunden sind, die an der Zellmembran stattfinden. Und jetzt hat man nicht nur eine einzige Nervenzelle oder viele Nervenzellen, die durcheinander liegen, sondern die Nervenzellen sind sehr stark geordnet im Gehirn. Die laufen senkrecht zur Gehirnoberfläche. Die sehr großen Nervenzellen sind alle senkrecht zur Oberfläche ausgerichtet. Und dadurch verstärken sich quasi die Felder, die die generieren, so dass man das an der Kopfoberfläche auch messen kann. Eigentlich sieht man sogenannte Populationssignale, also das kohärente Zusammenwirken von sehr vielen Nervenzellen, die im Kopf parallel angeordnet sind, also im Cortex parallel angeordnet sind.
Also kann man sich eigentlich so eine Nervenzelle so ein bisschen vorstellen wie so eine Baumwurzel. Ja, also der Input ist sozusagen so unten, wo das Wasser aufgenommen wird.
Genau, und das was dann quasi weiter gemeldet wird, also das Kabel, was quasi zur nächsten Nervenzelle geht, ist normalerweise erst mal nur ein Kabel und also da passt die Baumanalogie nicht mehr ganz so gut.
Ja, sagen wir mal so bis zum Stamm, den Rest habe ich jetzt mal ausgedrückt.
Genau, genau, und es gibt quasi einen Eingang, einen Ausgang und dazwischen gibt es eine Verrechnung, eigentlich eine sehr einfache Verrechnung dann in der Nervenzelle. Da wird einfach geschaut, ist genug Aktivität reingekommen, wenn genug reingekommen ist, dann gebe ich quasi die Information an die nächste Stelle weiter.
Das heißt, das was die eine Nervenzelle als Ausgabe erzeugt, ist dann so eins von mehreren Eingabeoptionen für die nächste Nervenzelle und so ist irgendwie alles miteinander verschaltet. Aber das ist jetzt keine reine Hierarchie?
Nein, nein, das ist sogar das Gegenteil einer Hierarchie. Wir wissen, dass das Gehirn sehr stark, so heißt das schon, rekurent verschaltet ist. Das heißt, normalerweise ist es reziprog, nicht in allen Fällen, aber es ist reziprog. Das heißt, eine Nervenzelle in einer Region gibt etwas an eine Nervenzelle in einer anderen Region. Und dann kommt es aus dieser Region auch wieder zurück zu der ersten Nervenzelle. Es ist also alles in solchen Schleifen angeordnet. Und das führt dazu, dass es manchmal ein bisschen unübersichtlich sein kann, zu verstehen, wie das Gehirn eigentlich im Detail funktioniert.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Kann man sich vorstellen, genau.
Manchmal ist es etwas unübersichtlich.
Ja, es ist eigentlich immer unübersichtlich. Deswegen kann man sich das jetzt so vorstellen als Ideal, dass man diese Kaskade von Prozessen durch das Gehirn hindurch verfolgen wollte. Also, als ob man immer an, es kommt jetzt etwas auf der Netzhaut an, und man will jetzt einfach gucken, wie das im Gehirn verarbeitet wird.
Ja, also wie sehe ich etwas, oder wie nehme ich ein Licht?
Jetzt könnte man sagen, ich setze mich einfach mal so wie Einstein, könnte ich mich jetzt einfach mal auf den ersten Spike setzen. Spike, so heißen diese Signale, die eine Nervenzelle an die andere schickt. Also null oder eins, ganz oder gar nicht. Wird dieses Signal weitergeleitet. Und jetzt setze ich mich einfach mal auf diesen Spike drauf. Da komme ich in der nächsten Zelle an, in der nächsten Region, und dann wird das auch ein bisschen verarbeitet, und dann wird wieder ein Spike produziert, und dann geht es wieder weiter. Und ich könnte mich ja einfach mal versuchen, das mal durchzuverfolgen. Das Problem ist, dass dann irgendwann so einer unglaublich komplizierten Überlagerung von nach vorne gerichteter Aktivität und quasi wieder Rückfluss von Information ist, also wie so ein Echo. Man gibt etwas in das System rein und dann überlagert sich das irgendwann, wie wenn man so ein Effektgerät nicht richtig eingestellt hat. Da kriegt man Feedback, und das muss natürlich auch alles richtig kalibriert werden. Ansonsten explodiert natürlich in Anführungsstrichen das auch, also die Netzwerkstabilität gerät dann außer Gefahr in Gefahr. Und das Feedforward, Feedback, also vorwärtsgerichtete, rückwärtsgerichtete Aktivitäten muss also auch in Balance sein.
Jetzt mit der Erfindung des EEG und der Entdeckung, dass da Ströme außen an den Hirnrinden, kann man ja nicht sagen, man setzt ja direkt auf der Haut auf. Also das heißt, da ist ja dann auch ein gewisser Abstand, bis das mal losgeht mit den Nervenzellen. Würde man ja erwarten, dass das eher ein sehr diffuses Echo ist. So als würde man so an der Wand lauschen, was der Nachbar macht. Und die Wand ist relativ dick. Was kann man denn diesen Daten dann überhaupt noch entnehmen? Also eigentlich kann man auch nur sehen, ob da überhaupt so generell irgendwie Aktivität ist oder nicht. Oder?
Ja, das EEG, ich muss mich dann vielleicht schon gleich bei allen Kollegen entschuldigen, die mit EEG arbeiten. Und das EEG ist schon sehr grob. Das EEG hat eine räumliche Auflösung von mehreren Zentimetern. Das heißt, man kann jetzt etwas, was jetzt dicht beieinander liegt im Gehirn, zwei verschiedene Nervenzellen, kann man jetzt nicht auseinanderhalten. Und man kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ob etwas im Sehsystem ist, also in dem Bereich unseres Gehirns, der fürs Sehen zuständig ist, also hinten ist das im Gehirn. Oder vielleicht etwas eher mit der Planungsinstanz des Gehirns, was mit dem sogenannten Präfrontalkortex zu tun hat. Dann kann man also sehen, ob die EEG-Aktivität über dem einen oder anderen Teil des Gehirns verstärkt ist. Aber die Auflösungsmöglichkeiten sind doch sehr begrenzt von EEG.
Aber was kann man denn da rauslesen? Man hat jetzt festgestellt, es gibt unterschiedliche Frequenzen, die für unterschiedliche Zustände stehen.
Genau, man ist bei den Frequenzen nicht stehen geblieben, sondern eine andere Sache, die man sich angeschaut hat, ist, immer wenn ich eine bestimmte Aufgabe gebe oder eine bestimmte Verarbeitung mache, dann hat man sich sogenannte ereigniskorrelierte Potenziale angeschaut. Das klingt jetzt erst mal sehr komplex, aber das bedeutet einfach nur, ich diese EEG-Wellen, das Alpha und Beta, das ist etwas, das beobachtet man einfach immer in der Hintergrundaktivität, wie so ein Brummen oder ein Rauschen im Hintergrund. Und jetzt hat man sich vielleicht dafür interessiert, was hängt dann mit einer spezifischen Verarbeitung zusammen? Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Rechenaufgabe durchführe oder ein Bild erkenne. Und was man dann gemacht hat, ist, man hat einfach, nehmen wir mal das einfachste Beispiel, man zeigt verschiedene Bilder. Und immer, wenn man jetzt ein Bild gezeigt hat, dann misst man, wie das Gehirn darauf reagiert. Da sieht man erst mal nichts, weil diese Hintergrundwellen, dieses Rauschen, ist sehr, sehr stark. Jetzt mittelt man das über ganz, ganz viele Durchgänge und dann sieht man, dass das Gehirn also auf eine bestimmte systematische Art und Weise reagiert darauf, wenn ich dem Gehirn zum Beispiel Bilder zeige. Dann gibt es also eine bestimmte Abfolge von positiven und negativen Ausschlägen im EEG. Und diese Ausschläge passieren am Anfang im Sehsystem und dann wird es zunehmend breiter im Gehirn verarbeitet. Man kann also schon ein bisschen was Präziseseres sagen. Man kann zum Beispiel dadurch auch auf die zeitliche Abfolge von Prozessen schließen. Und das ist der große Vorteil des EEG gegenüber der Kern-Dynamographie. Die räumliche Auflösung ist nicht besonders gut, aber die zeitliche Auflösung ist extrem gut. Wir können da mit einem Kilohertz messen und alles sehr, sehr fein auflösen. Und da kann man dann schon auch zeitliche Prozesse...
1000 Messpunkte pro Sekunde generieren.
1000 Messpunkte pro Sekunde. Dem steht nichts im Wege. Und man kann das schon sehr, sehr fein auflösen, zeitlich. Und das bedeutet, dass der große Einsatzgebiet des EEG war, als man sich dafür interessiert hat, welcher Prozess kommt denn zum Beispiel zuerst? Also, wenn man jetzt so zwei verschiedene Aufgaben machen würde oder wenn man so mutale Aufgaben rechnen würde, welche Abstufung von diesen Aufgaben werden jetzt zuerst durchgeführt? Also für solche Fragen ist das EEG sehr gut geeignet. Für die genaue Lokalisation im Gehirn, wenn man wissen möchte, das ist jetzt wirklich genau da und nicht woanders im Gehirn, da würde man eher zu der Kernschwind-Tomographie greifen, die dann als Technik in der funktionellen Hirnforschung erst in den 90er Jahren aufgekommen ist, das letzten Jahrhunderts. Das hat also noch lange auf sich warten lassen.
Wann kam das EEG? 70er, sagtest du, oder?
Das EEG wurde, ich glaube, die erste Publikation dazu war 1929 von Herrn Berger aus Jena. Das hat natürlich eine Weile gedauert, bis sich das so breiter durchgesetzt hat. Dabei in den 60er und 70er-Jahren findet man schon sehr, sehr viele EEG-Studien. Dann kamen in den 80er-Jahren irgendwann auch die Prositronen-Emissions-Tomographie dazu, wo man mit radioaktiven Markern arbeitet und mit Detektorringen, bei denen man dann also auch Metabolismus, also Stoffwechsel im Gehirn sichtbar machen kann. Und in den 90er-Jahren, frühen 90er-Jahren, kam dann die sogenannte funktionelle Kernspintomographie, die heute eigentlich so das Arbeitspferd der menschlichen Hirnforschung ist. Dazu, womit man die Hirnaktivitätsmuster räumlich viel feiner auflösen kann.
Das heißt, das waren jetzt die wesentlichen Meilensteine für die Messung von Hirnaktivitäten, die drei Sachen EEG, Positronen, Emissionstomographie. Was heißt das? Da muss man dann eine Flüssigkeit einnehmen, oder was die dann im Hirn rumliegt?
Genau, es wird injiziert. Es wird injiziert, also ein Tracer injiziert. Und dann kann man quasi über den Zerfall, den kann man mit einem Detektorring dann messen.
Also radioaktiver Zerfall.
Genau, und deswegen ist es auch, es ist keine starke Dosis, der man da ausgesetzt ist. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass man immer versucht ist, die Probanden vor jeglichen Schaden zu schützen. Und deswegen hat eigentlich in der Grundlagenforschung die funktionelle Kernschmitt-Tomografie das PET abgelöst mit der einfachen Begründung, dass die funktionelle Kernschmitt-Tomografie mit keinen Gefahren verbunden ist, während hingegen die positronen Emissions-Tomografie mit einer leichten radioaktiven Dosis verbunden ist. Also das PET spielt heute nicht mehr die große Rolle, die es in den 80er-Jahren gespielt hat. Auch die Auflösungsfähigkeit vom PET ist nicht so gut.
Aber was hat denn diese technische Entwicklung jetzt für die Erkenntnisse über das Hirn geliefert? Also das EEG, okay, damit war dann überhaupt schon mal klar, da spielt sich was mit Strom ab. Das ist ja im Prinzip die Aussage.
Das hätte man schon vorher gewusst, weil man ja die grundlegende Biologie des Gehirns, die kannte man ja schon früher, die kannte man schon 100 Jahre früher. Was man damit zum ersten Mal gezeigt hat, war, dass man es beim Menschen messen kann, ohne dass man, ich sag jetzt mal, eindringen muss, den Schädel öffnen muss, was natürlich ein gewaltiger Fortschritt ist.
Aber es war noch bis dahin eigentlich nur eine Vermutung, dass das irgendwie auf Strom basiert.
Ja, nicht unbedingt, weil ja, das war schon klar, weil man wusste ja von anderen Tieren, die konnte man ja untersuchen, da konnte man einfach invasiv messen.
Achso, da wurde einfach mal was reingesteckt.
Genau, das hat man schon gewusst, wie die Nervenzelle grob funktioniert. Was Berger eigentlich ausgezeichnet hat, war, dass er zum ersten Mal ein richtig nicht-invasives Verfahren, also ein Verfahren, wo man den Menschen überhaupt gar keinen Schaden zufügt, verwenden, entwickeln kann. Und damit doch immer noch, obwohl man auf der Oberfläche des Gehirns aufsitzt oder auf der Oberfläche des Schädels, also es ist ja einfach eine Kappe, die man aufsetzt, dass man damit dann etwas messen konnte, was mit der geistigen Aktivität des Probanden zu tun hat. Aber es hat jetzt nicht radikal das Bild über das Gehirn verändert, würde ich sagen. Also was dann wirklich das Bild radikal verändert hat, war dann mit der Kernspintomographie, dass es dann zu einer systematischen Kartierung des Gehirns gekommen ist.
Das heißt, das hat das PET auch noch nicht geleistet?
Ja, ein bisschen hat es das geleistet. Die Auflösungsfähigkeit war nicht so gut. Ich meine, es gab zwar viele Arbeitsgruppen, die das gemacht haben, aber so richtig losgetreten ist es dann eigentlich erst durch die funktuelle Kernspintomographie geworden in den 90er-Jahren, die eine bessere zeitliche Auflösung hat als das PET und eine bessere räumliche Auflösung als das PET und die auch einfach überhaupt nicht mit Gefahren für den Probanden verbunden ist.
Also Kernspin, man sagt, glaube ich, Magnetresonanz-Tomographie. Das heißt, da gibt es jetzt die Magnetresonanz-Tomographie und die funktionelle.
Genau, es sind zwei verschiedene Dinge. Also man benutzt dafür das gleiche Gerät. Also der Kernspintomograph ist also der gleiche, den man in beiden Fällen benutzt. Man benutzt ihn nur für eine andere Art von Messung. Man kann grob sagen, dass man zwei verschiedene Arten von Messungen machen kann mit so einem Kernspintomograph. Also vielleicht erst mal kurz zur Erklärung. Kernspintomograph kennt vielleicht nicht jeder den Begriff, aber das sind diese großen Röhren, in die man reingebracht wird. Man liegt also auf so einem Patiententisch auf dem Rücken und wird dann da reingeschoben und kann dann die Hirn-Messungen durchführen. Da gibt es jetzt diese zwei verschiedenen... Es gibt dann laute Geräusche. Normalerweise hat man deswegen auch Ohrenstöpsel, um sich gegen die lauten Geräusche zu schützen. Manche Menschen mögen es auch nicht, weil es halt sehr eng ist in dieser Röhre. Deswegen versucht man dann halt auch, so Bilder zu zeigen. Da gibt es so ein Videopräsentationssystem da drin und man kann dann Töne projizieren und man kann dann also auch mit den Probanden sprechen und so weiter. Es ist für manche Menschen schon unangenehm, in so einen Tomographen zu gehen.
Macht keinen Spaß.
Aber es ist ein Teil der Probanden, denen das so etwas ausmacht. Andere haben damit kein Problem.
Was macht jetzt der Tomograph genau?
Genau, also was macht der Tomograph? Der Tomograph besteht erstmal aus einem sehr starken Magnetfeld. Da gibt es verschiedene Magnetfeldstärken, aber die gängigen, die in der Klinik benutzt werden, sind zurzeit bei 1,5 Tesla ungefähr. Und in der Forschung benutzt man jetzt drei Tesla bzw. noch höhere Feldstärken. Und was man jetzt damit macht mit diesem Kernschmitt-Tomographen, kommen wir vielleicht noch mal kurz auf diese zwei Arten von Messungen zurück. Man kann damit einerseits die Hirnstruktur messen, dann weiß man also welcher Gewebe-Typ, man kriegt dann ein Bild des Gehirns.
Wie entsteht denn dieses Bild überhaupt?
Okay, jetzt können wir auch darüber sprechen. Das Bild entsteht darüber, dass man also dieses starke Magnetfeld hat. Und jetzt ist es so, dass die, mit Magnetfeld allein ist es nicht getan, sondern dann bringt man eine Radiofrequenz ein, die mit den Protonen des Wassers in Resonanz tritt und einige von denen in einen höher energetischen Zustand bringt. Die sind dann aber nicht so lange in diesem höher energetischen Zustand, sondern das fällt dann quasi wieder ab. Damit kann man erst einmal überhaupt ein Signal messen, das von den Protonen des Wassers getragen wird. Und jetzt, also damit kriegt man überhaupt erst einmal ein Signal aus dem Gehirn, quasi so ein Echo-Signal, was aus dem Gehirn zurückkommt. Und jetzt kann man das Ganze noch...
Also nicht nur aus dem Gehirn, sondern sozusagen alles, was Wasser ist an unserem Körper.
Genau, also es würde jetzt erst einmal alles, alle Protonen in Wassermolekülen würden jetzt auf eine bestimmte Resonanzfrequenz reagieren und würden dadurch ausgelenkt werden in einen höher energetischen Zustand und fallen dann nach einer Weile wieder zurück und geben dabei so ein Signal ab. Das ist erst einmal das grundlegende Signal, was man messen kann. Und das ist erst einmal, also man misst jetzt nicht den ganzen Körper, sondern normalerweise misst man einen Teil des Körpers, zum Beispiel den Kopf, wenn man sich für den Kopf interessiert. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kommt die räumliche Kodierung da rein? Da hat man jetzt erst einmal nur den Kopf als Ganzes angeregt, zum Beispiel, wenn es jetzt so wäre. Und die räumliche Kodierung kommt darüber zustande, dass zum einen diese Resonanzfrequenz dieser Protonen davon abhängt, wie stark das lokale Magnetfeld gerade ist. Das heißt, wenn man also die Magnetfeldstärke variiert, dann kann man also dafür sorgen, dass nur bestimmte Protonen, also die in Wasser gebunden sind, überhaupt reagieren auf diese Radiofrequenz, die man da reinbringt. Und jetzt, was macht man folgendes? Da setzt man einen sogenannten Gradienten an. Magnetfeldgradient, das heißt, das Magnetfeld ist an dem Scanner von vorne bis hinten nicht konstant, sondern das Magnetfeld wird durch ein zusätzliches Magnetfeld, ein variables Magnetfeld noch geändert, sodass es an jeder Stelle ein bisschen anders ist. Und jetzt kann man quasi, dadurch, dass es nur an einer Stelle genau die richtige Magnetfeldstärke hat, wo dann die Protonen in Resonanz treten mit der Radiofrequenz, dadurch kann man erstmal eine Schicht auswählen. Und jetzt kann man durch eine Geschickenspielerei, die sicherlich jetzt sehr weit führen würde, das im Detail auseinanderzunehmen, kann man noch andere Gradienten schalten und damit quasi dieses Bild räumlich auflösen nochmal.
Das heißt, dadurch fokussiert man quasi auf einen bestimmten Punkt und guckt dann, was resoniert oder resoniert da überhaupt was.
Ja, man fokussiert erstmal auf eine Schicht und dann wählt man also eine Schicht aus und in dieser Schicht kann man dann tatsächlich ein zweidimensionales Bild rekonstruieren durch eine Verschiebung anderer Gradienten.
Was ist die eigentliche Information, die man da jetzt abbildet?
Ja, also erstmal kommt zurück, erstmal Radiofrequenz und diese Radiofrequenz kann man in ein Bild rekonstruieren. Dann kriegt man also ein zweidimensionales Bild, der Schicht, die man gerade angeregt hat.
Aber was ist die Information in diesem Bild?
Die Information, genau, was die widerspiegelt. Ja, die spiegelt verschiedene Dinge wieder, je nachdem, für welche Art von Messung man sich gerade interessiert. Man kann zum einen sich für die Hirnstruktur interessieren, dann bekommt man etwas, was vor allen Dingen Hirnstruktur-Aspekte widerspiegelt. Oder man kann sich für die Funktion des Gehirns, also die Aktivität des Gehirns interessieren, und dann spiegelt diese Messung eher aktivitätsbezogene Aspekte wieder.
Das da unterschied ja zwischen der eigentlichen, normalen MLT und der funktionellen.
Genau, also ob dieses Bild, also man kann den Scanner ganz platt verschieden einstellen, und wenn man jetzt die eine Einstellung wählt, dann ist das Bild, was man dann von dieser angeregten Schicht zurückkriegt, bildet die Struktur ab, oder es bildet die Aktivität des Gehirns ab.
Also das eine ist, wie sieht es aus, und das andere ist, was macht es gerade?
Wunderbar formuliert, genau, und was es gerade macht, muss man auch noch wissen, was bedeutet dieses Bild dann, was es gerade macht. Dieses Bild, was es gerade macht, zeigt vor allen Dingen Bereiche, wo die Sauerstoff-Sättigung des Blutes sich verändert. Das ist nämlich so, wenn man, also man muss sich erstmal fragen, warum sollte man überhaupt mit einem magnetischen Verfahren messen können, wo das Gehirn aktiv ist. Und wenn man sagt, das Gehirn ist aktiv, ist das bewusst nebulös formuliert, weil was wir nicht messen, ist die Aktivität einzelner Nervenzellen. Sondern es gibt eine Kaskade, und wir messen etwas, was später in dieser Kaskade auftritt. Es ist jetzt so, dass die Nervenzelle wird aktiv, die Nervenzelle braucht Sauerstoff und entzieht dem umgehenden Gewebe und dem Blut dann Sauerstoff. Und dann, das ist quasi die erste Phase, und danach passiert Folgendes, es gibt quasi so eine Gegenregulierung des Gefäßsystems des Gehirns, was dazu führt, dass mehr Sauerstoff da reingepumpt wird, sodass zum Schluss mehr sauerstoffhaltiges Blut in diesem kleinen Bereich des Gehirns vorzufinden ist. Und jetzt muss man noch dazu wissen, dass sich die magnetischen Eigenschaften des Blutes unterscheiden, je nachdem, ob das Blut gerade Sauerstoff, also das Hämoglobin gerade Sauerstoff bindet oder nicht. Man kann sich das so ähnlich vorstellen wie bei einem Auto oder bei Rost. Also wenn man, ich sage es mal ganz platt gesagt, das ist nicht Stahl, aber stellen wir mal vor, das Auto würde aus Eisen bestehen, dann sagen wir sehr sehr altes Auto. Und dann, wenn es noch neu ist, dann hat es also keinen Sauerstoff gebunden und dann hängt der Magnet, den kann man wunderbar da dran machen, ist also magnetisch, wenn es keinen Sauerstoff bindet. Und wenn das Ding verrostet ist, dann hält der Magnet nicht mehr dran. Und so ist es einfach so eine Eselsbrücke, wie man sich das merken kann. Also das heißt, dass die magnetischen Eigenstoffen des Eisenatoms sich ändern, wenn Sauerstoff gebunden ist. Und das ist auch genau so, wie das Hemoglobin, den das Sauerstoff bindet, das ist von der Lunge dann zu der Zelle transportiert.
Alles klar, verstehe.
Ich bin jetzt kein Biologe.
Ja, wenn ich es schon verstanden habe, im Prinzip diese Magnetresonanz-Tomographie arbeitet halt mit Magnetfeldern, nutzt einige Tricks, dass man sich eben auf so geografische Punkte machen kann. Und die Auflösung ist ja relativ hoch. Was erzielt man so für eine Auflösung?
Ja, man kann eine Auflösung, also strukturell, kann man eine Auflösung erzielen von einem Zehntel Millimeter. Das kann man also wirklich sehr fein auflösen. Die Funktion kann man nicht ganz so fein auflösen, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Da nimmt man normalerweise Auflösungen so zwischen 1 und 3 Millimetern, die es in zur Gangung gäbe.
Aber das ist ja jetzt auch nicht ohne. Also das heißt, man kann im Prinzip das komplette Gehirn kartografieren, was da gerade aktivitätenmäßig los ist. Aber das dauert natürlich auch eine Weile, bis man da einmal durch ist durch das Hirn. Da ist ja schon wieder viel passiert.
Genau, das dauert so 2-3 Sekunden. Also die zeitliche Auflösung, im Gegensatz zum EEG, also ist die zeitliche Auflösung der Kernschwindentomographie, der Funktion der Kernschwindentomographie schlecht. Sprich, das EEG misst instantan die elektrische Aktivität, die zu tun hat mit einem Gedanken, den man hat.
Das halt dann einstellt gleichzeitig.
Genau, aber hat halt keine räumliche Auflösung. Die Kernschwindentomographie, die Funktion der Kernschwindentomographie, hat eine sehr hohe räumliche Auflösung, aber das kommt quasi um den Preis, dass die zeitliche Auflösung sehr schlecht ist. Das heißt, das dauert erst mal so 2 Sekunden, 3 Sekunden, je nachdem, wie man es macht, das Bild aufzuzeichnen, dass man einmal durchs ganze Gehirn durch ist und macht ja Schicht für Schicht.
Tut sich da nicht gerade was in diesem technischen Bereich, dass es irgendwie schnellere MRTs gibt, die jetzt gerade eingeführt wurden?
Ja, was vor allen Dingen passiert, ist höhere Feldstärken. Es gibt natürlich auch andere Art und Weisen, die Tomographen zu nutzen, womit man dann schnellere Bilder machen kann, aber was sich vor allen Dingen tut, sind höhere Feldstärken und diese höheren Feldstärken sind auch sehr interessant, also höher als drei Tesla, also in etwa 7, 9,4 und so weiter. Es gibt verschiedene Standorte, also in Berlin gibt es hier zum Beispiel in Buch gibt es das 7-Tesla-Gerät und in Leipzig am Max-Planck-Institut und in Magdeburg gibt es auch ein 7-Tesla-Gerät. Und was da so der große Vorteil ist von diesen Geräten, ist es vor allen Dingen für strukturelle Bildgebung interessant, weil man da sehr stark die Auflösung nochmal verbessern kann. Das hat also große Vorteile, wenn man zu größeren Feldstärken geht.
Auch für die funktionelle Auswertung?
Für die funktionelle Auswertung ist es so, im Moment müssen da noch Verfahren gefunden werden, mit denen man das Maximum da rausholt. Aber auch da können wir hoffen, dass die Zukunft uns da auch eine bessere Auflösung in funktioneller Hinsicht bringen wird.
Gut, also diese funktionelle Magnetresonanztomographie ist jetzt quasi der nächste Schlüssel gewesen bei der Hirnforschung, wo man gesagt hat, okay, jetzt können wir mal so richtig reingucken. Man kann jetzt aber nicht so dem Hirn an allen Stellen gleichzeitig wirklich zuschauen. Aber was kann man denn machen? Wie lange dauert so ein Scan jetzt so durch ein durchschnittlich großes Hirn?
Ja, also der Scan durch das Gehirn dauert, wie gesagt, ungefähr zwei bis drei Sekunden. Das heißt, damit bekommt man ein Bild. Instantan, das ist jetzt der Aktivitätszustand des Gehirns. Man muss noch dazu sagen, es gibt so verschiedene zeitliche Aspekte dabei. Also das eine ist, wie lange dauert es, bis ich das gemessen habe. Das andere ist, wenn ich das gemessen habe, wie ist denn die zeitliche Auflösung des biologischen Signals, das ich messe? Ich habe erzählt, dass wir nicht die Nervenzellaktivität messen, sondern wir messen den Sauerstoffgehalt des Blutes. Es dauert es aber auch eine Weile, bis sich diese Sauerstoffgehaltänderung im Blut eingestellt haben. Es dauert mehrere Sekunden. Das ist so ähnlich, wie wenn man etwas Peinliches gesagt hat und man wird rot. Es gibt dann auch diese leichte Verzögerung. Man weiß genau, dass es kommt. Es ist einmal etwas peinlich. Dann wird man mit mehreren Sekunden Verspätung rot.
Es ist ein bisschen, als würde man einen Kriegsschauplatz beobachten, indem man guckt, wie die Munitionsversorgung so läuft. Man hat da einfach einen Delay.
Ja, es gibt eine Verzögerung, ganz genau. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt fein zeitlich aufgelöste Information braucht, genau zum Zeitpunkt, wann der Gedanke aufgetreten ist, seine Person hat oder eine geistige Leistung vollbracht wurde, dann geht es eigentlich nur mit EEG. Aber um den Preis der schlechteren räumlichen Auflösung. Wenn man es mit der funktionalen Catchment-Tomographie macht, hängt man immer ein bisschen hinterher. Nun ist es für die Forschung nicht so problematisch, sondern man weiß ja ziemlich genau, wie lange man hinterherhängt und kann das dann quasi rausrechnen. Das ist eigentlich im Forschungsalltag gar nicht so problematisch. Es gibt eine Reihe von Umwegen, die man gehen kann, um dann doch eine gewisse zeitliche Auflösung zu bekommen. Aber man muss erst mal sagen, das ist erst mal einer der Nachteile der funktionalen Catchment-Tomographie. Jetzt tut man probanten in den Scanner. Und jetzt gibt man den über eine Periode von zehn Minuten oder eine halbe Stunde liegt er dann im Scanner und man gibt ihm bestimmte Aufgaben. Und während er dann diese Aufgaben bearbeitet, misst man dann die Hirnaktivität.
Was für Aufgaben sind das so? Macht er Aufgaben? Lesen oder was?
Also das ist ein Forschungsgebiet, wo jährlich zig Paper publiziert werden, also zig Tausend Paper sicherlich. Und ich habe es nie nachgezählt, aber die Lage wird alles, was man sich so vorstellen kann, wird untersucht bis hin zu den neuronalen Korrelaten, religiöser Erlebnisse oder neuronale Korrelate, Reste der Liebe und haste nicht gesehen. Also da wird alles, was man sich so vorstellen kann, an mentaler Aktivität, wird auch im Scanner untersucht. Das unterscheidet die Periode davor von der Periode ab den frühen 90er Jahren. Danach ging es wirklich generalstabsmäßig durch das Gehirn. Alle Funktionen wurden untersucht und rauf und runter mit verschiedenen Aufgaben. Und seitdem hat sich eigentlich dieses Feld der sogenannten kognitiven Neurowissenschaften, also der Erforschung, wie unsere mentalen Fähigkeiten mit dem menschlichen Gehirn zusammenhängen, das zu kartieren, das hat sich seitdem eigentlich erst so richtig entwickelt, muss man sagen, als Forschungsgebiet.
Einschließlich Sex?
Ja, auch Sex und Repräsentation des menschlichen Geschlechtsorgans und so weiter. Das war nämlich irgendwann mal falsch abgebildet, das hat dann so eine Kollegin noch mal korrigiert. Also da gibt es alle möglichen Varianten.
So das ist aber jetzt in den 90ern losgegangen?
Genau, frühe 90er Jahre losgegangen. Weil man da erst so richtig begriffen hat, dass die Sauerstoffänderung des Blutes sich mit so einem Kernschmuck mit Tomografen messen lässt. Das hat man da einfach erst so richtig verstanden und die Bausteine des Puzzles zusammengesetzt. Und deswegen kam es überhaupt erst da auf. Die Kernschmuck mit Tomografen waren ja schon länger auch klinisch genutzt, aber da hat man erst mal verstanden, dass man damit auch die Hirnaktivität messen könnte.
Das heißt, diese funktionelle Methodie ist quasi jetzt der neue Aspekt.
Das ist der neue Dreh, mit dem dann so eine richtige Exklusion in diesem Bereich der Hirnforschung losgetreten worden ist.
Ja, da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was sind jetzt so die Erkenntnisse? Vielleicht nochmal kurz, meine, wir haben ja vorhin schon mal so den Blick auch ins Hirn gewagt. Also die Neuronen und so ihre baumartige Struktur und ihre zirkuläre Vernetzung untereinander. Ist es das eigentlich schon? Also ist das das, was das Hirn im Wesentlichen ausmacht? Oder kommen da noch andere Komponenten mit ins Spiel?
Ja, also die entscheidende, um die Funktion des Gehirns zu verstehen, reicht es nicht, die einzelnen Nervenzellen zu verstehen. Das ist zwar manchmal so, vielleicht wenn man einzelne Nervenzellen oder sogar Bestandteile von Nervenzellen wissenschaftlich untersucht, dass man das glaubt. Aber die entscheidende Leistung ist ja dann die Zusammenschaltung. Das ist so, wie man einen Computer nicht verstehen kann. Wenn man weiß, was einer der Chips im Computer macht, so kann man das Gehirn auch nicht verstehen. Wenn man weiß, wie einer dieser Nervenzellen funktioniert.
Das ist so, als würde man sich nur einen Transistor anschauen.
Das ist so, als würde man sich genau nur einen Transistor anschauen. Und entscheidend sind nicht die Verschaltung dieser vielen Nervenzellen. Und daraus überhaupt erst kann man verstehen, wie eine bestimmte Leistung vollbracht wird. Man hat also, wenn man, ich sag jetzt mal, jede Art von geistiger Leistung ist ein Netzwerk-Phenomen. Man muss also immer verstehen, wie viele Nervenzellen zusammenarbeiten, um zu verstehen, wie diese Leistung realisiert wird. Und das heißt also, die Verschaltung ist das, worauf man hinaus sollte. Das ist natürlich schwer. Wir haben 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen. Und dann noch mal genau nachzuvollziehen, welcher dieser 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen mit welchen anderen Nervenzellen genau verschaltet ist. Das ist eine Sisyphos-Arbeit, die natürlich niemand leisten kann. Und vor allen Dingen nicht leisten kann, bei einem gesunden Menschen ohne dem Menschen irgendwelche Schaden zuzufügen. Also es geht einfach nicht. Muss also mit dem arbeiten, was man hat mit diesen makroskopischen Verfahren. Und was man da gemacht hat, ist vor allen Dingen erst mal die Kartierung. Man hat sich also gefragt, wenn jetzt jemand etwas sieht, wenn jemand etwas hört, wenn jemand etwas plant, wenn jemand etwas erinnert, wenn jemand etwas im Kurzzeitgedächtnis behält, wenn jemand bestimmte Emotionen hat, wenn jemand eine Belohnung kriegt, wenn jemand seine Aufmerksamkeit irgendwo hinrichtet, hat man quasi kartiert, welche Bereiche des Gehirns sind aktiv, wenn so was passiert. Sodass man also zum ersten Mal so richtig nachvollziehen konnte, welche Teile des Gehirns sind denn an welchen Leistungen überhaupt beteiligt. Vorher konnte man das eigentlich nur machen mit der Neurologie und Neuropsychologie. Das war immer so ein bisschen indirekt. Wenn man wusste, ein Patient hat man das gemacht, wenn der irgendwo eine bestimmte Schädigung des Gehirns hatte und da gab es ein Defizit, dann konnte man sich denken, dass dann vielleicht diese Funktion da lokalisiert war.
Das waren im Prinzip die Ergebnisse von dem Brotmann, die Brotmann-Ariane.
Ja und viele andere. Also die ganze Geschichte der Neuropsychologie, da geht es also auch immer um die Frage, welche Funktionen fallen aus, wenn ich das Gehirn wo schädige. Man muss sagen, es hat eine gewisse Schwierigkeit, wenn man einfach nur das als Datenbasis hat, weil man natürlich aus dem Ausfallen nicht schließen kann, dass die Funktion da lokalisiert ist. Also man kann jetzt z.B. nicht sagen, wenn man den Anlass aus dem Auto ausbaut, dann fährt das Auto nicht und deswegen ist das Fahren im Anlass realisiert. Das ist natürlich ein Fehlschluss, sondern wenn ein Teil ausfällt, können ganz andere Netzwerke auch mit in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden. Und deswegen braucht man komplementär zu diesem Bild natürlich auch das Bild, welche Bereiche sind denn aktiv bei einer bestimmten Aufgabe, um so ein etwas differenzierteres Bild davon zu bekommen, wie jetzt verschiedene geistige Prozesse im Gehirn realisiert sind.
Also im Prinzip kartiert man die Abhängigkeiten der einzelnen Bereiche.
Genau, genau, man zeigt, also eine Region ist vielleicht am Sehen beteiligt, eine andere Region ist im höherwertigen Sehen beteiligt, also die eine sieht vielleicht nur Ecken und Kanten, analysiert erst mal das Bild sehr grob, die nächste erkennt schon, um was für ein Objekt es sich handeln könnte, eine andere Region erkennt, was für ein Objekt es ist, würde aber auch anspringen, wenn man das nicht als Bild sieht, sondern vielleicht hört, also sagen wir, jemand sagt Katze oder man zeigt ein Bild von einer Katze. Und jetzt gibt es die ersten Verarbeitungsstufen, da weiß man, die extrahieren quasi erstmal den Umriss der Katze. Und die nächste Verarbeitungsstufe, die verarbeitet vielleicht so die einfachen Formen, so Rund, Schnoh, Haare und so weiter, Schwanz, solche einfachen Bausteine. Die nächste Region erkennt dann, dass es eine Katze ist. Aber dann gibt es quasi noch weitere Regionen, die dann auch dann reagieren und erkennen, dass es eine Katze ist, wenn man zum Beispiel das Wort Katze liest oder das Wort Katze hört, also in ganz anderen Kontexten oder nur an eine Katze denkt. So gibt es quasi so zunehmende Stufen der Abstraktion. Und sowas kann man mit diesem Kernschmettermografie-Verfahren sehr gut kartieren.
Wenn man jetzt nicht 85 Milliarden Neuronen einzeln anschauen will, aber auch mit der Singularität, dass das Gehirn nicht ausreicht, sondern dass man quasi sagt, wir müssen Bereiche unterscheiden. Wie viele Bereiche muss man denn unterscheiden? Oder kann man unterscheiden? Das gehört jetzt auch so weit zusammen, da ist jetzt nicht noch eine 2. und 3. Funktionalität drin abgebildet. Wie viele Gruppen ergeben sich aus dieser Betrachtung eigentlich?
Ja, also man muss es auf verschiedenen Auflösungsstufen sehen. Wir haben die 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen, dann haben wir die Brotmann-Ariale, dann haben wir innerhalb der Brotmann-Ariale wiederum Unterteilungen. Das sind auch nicht homogen diese Brotmann-Ariale, sondern die sind auch wieder unterteilt. Und da gibt es dann auch wieder eine Struktur da drin. Also man kann sich das einfach so vorstellen, vielleicht wie so eine Gesellschaft organisiert ist. Und so ganz viele verschiedene Strukturen, je nachdem auf welcher Auflösungsebene man sich interessiert gibt, ist die Antwort auch ein bisschen anders.
So die Männer, aber dann eben auch noch der Unterteil der Männer oder so.
Genau, soziale Schicht und so weiter, Alter. Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Unterteilungsmöglichkeiten und so ist es mit dem Gehirn auch. Grob könnte man vielleicht von so zehn, fünfzehn Funktionen sprechen, die erstmal so die Wesentlichen sind, die man untersucht. Also ich nenne mal einfach nur ein paar Klassiker. Das wären sensorische, also Wahrnehmung, Sehsinn, Hörsinn und so weiter, Hasssinn. Dann haben wir Erinnerung. Wir haben Sprache, wir haben Aufmerksamkeit, wir haben Planung, wir haben also Gefühl, also quasi die emotionale Färbung, wir haben die Verarbeitung von Belohnung und quasi Planung unseres Verhaltens auf der Basis von Belohnung. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Funktionen, die wir haben, die jetzt so die einzelnen Forschungsfelder in dem Gebiet ausmachen, wo dann die Leute innerhalb dieses Forschungsfelds schon so ungefähr wissen, was die anderen machen, aber dann aus zwischen diesen Forschungsfeldern gibt es dann nicht unbedingt immer so viel Austausch, weil dann wieder ganz andere Themen bearbeitet werden. Also jemand, der übers Gedächtnis forscht, weiß nicht unbedingt was über die neuronale Realisierung von Emotionen zum Beispiel. Es teilt sich also durch die Komplexität des Gebietes, teilt es sich schon in viele, mehr oder weniger unabhängig arbeitende Teilgebiete auf.
Aber gibt es denn da, wenn ich jetzt dieser Vergleich mit wie in unserer Gesellschaft, sondern meinte ich Männer, du meintest soziale Schlicht, heißt das, dass man sozusagen auch noch mal, je nachdem wie man draufblickt, andere Überlappungen hat, weil es gibt natürlich in der sozialen Schlicht Männer und Frauen. Also es ist so eine klare Hierarchie, dass man jetzt wirklich sagen kann hier geografisch, dieser Bereich ist ein kleinster Teil von dieser übergeordneten Gruppe oder gehört ein Teil, der sich so lokalisieren lässt, mal zu einer Gruppe, mal zu einer anderen Gruppe.
Es ist recht klar, dass sich das nicht hierarchisch gestaltet, sondern dass eine Region an vielen verschiedenen Funktionen teilnehmen kann.
Also mal ist sie Teil davon, mal ist sie Teil davon.
Genau, das ist so wechselnde Koalition. Also das ist jetzt nicht einfach so schön hierarchisch, es gibt quasi die Bereiche, die jetzt immer nur einer klaren Funktion, die hierarchisch geordnet sind, zuzuordnen sind.
Okay, aber was ist dann da sozusagen das Atom? Also wie viele Kleinstbereiche muss man jetzt unterscheiden, um die Gesamtaktivität ablesen zu können, zu wollen?
Auf die Frage gibt es keine Antwort. Das ist je nachdem, wie viele verschiedene Funktionen einen interessieren. Da kann man dann immer schauen, was ist denn das Bild, wie das im Gehirn realisiert wird.
Na gut, aber mehr als 85 Milliarden sind es nicht so. Wahrscheinlich mindestens Millionen oder tausende oder hunderte. Also in welcher Größenordnung muss man jetzt hier denken?
Nehmen wir mal die Analogie des Computers vielleicht wieder. Das ist so, als ob man fragt, welche Bausteine des Computers gibt es? Man kann das auf vielen verschiedenen Auflösungsebenen betrachten. Das gibt nicht für das Verständnis, sind eigentlich alle wichtig, wenn man wirklich versteht, wie ein Computer funktioniert. Aber wenn man fragt, wie viele Funktionen kann der Computer realisieren, dann sagt man, so viele wie einem einfallen. Und so ist es beim Gehirn auch. Man kann das grob unterteilen in verschiedene Funktionen und die zugehörigen Netzwerke, die das realisieren. Man weiß, dass diese Netzwerke sich teilweise überlappen. Aber so etwas wie ein Atom, eine elementare Einheit, gibt es vielleicht in der Nervenzelle, könnte man sagen. Oder in ganz kleinen Verbänden von Nervenzellen. Aber viel mehr, was anderes wird man da nicht finden. Okay, alles nicht so einfach. Alles nicht so einfach, das stimmt. Es gibt also, über diese sehr komplizierte Struktur kann man natürlich viele Vereinfachungen erzählen. Aber diese Vorstellung von einem Atom ist natürlich sehr stark dem geschuldet, wie man sich sonst vielleicht technische Geräte vorstellt. Also man zerlegt dann seine Bausteine.
Ich sehe, ein Atom war jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht die beste Bezeichnung. Das hat ja schon beim Atom nicht funktioniert. Dass das dann sozusagen auch nur ein Baustein ist. Aber wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, mit dem Kernspinnen, mit der Kernspinnen-Methode hergehe und jetzt bleiben wir vielleicht mal bei, ich denke an Katze, wie muss ich mir das jetzt vorstellen, wie viele unterschiedliche Regionen werden dann in dem Moment, sind dann zu unterscheiden, um das sozusagen aufzunehmen, dass diese Reaktionen, wie viele Koalitionen teilt sich das Hirn in dem Moment, wo es um das Wort Katze geht?
Also du möchtest gerne Zahl hören.
Ich würde gerne eine Größenordnung erfüllen.
Es ist ganz klar, wenn ich an Katze denke, dann sind weiträumige Bereiche meines Gehirns aktiv. Und zwar je nachdem, wie viele verschiedene Assoziationen ich mit der Katze habe, wie viele verschiedene Aspekte ich über die Katze denken kann, dafür ist dann wiederum immer eine neue Koalition von Nervenzellen beteiligt. Also ich kann an die Katze denken, ich kann an ihre Farbe denken, ich kann an ihre Schnurrhaare denken, ich kann an die Katze denken, die ich früher hatte, die immer auf meinem Schoß gesessen hat, ich kann an die Katze denken, die mich gekratzt hat. Verschiedene Gefühlseben sind dabei, Farben sind dabei, ich kann das Miauen hören der Katze, ich kann verschiedene Arten von Miaus hören, ich kann ganz unterschiedlichste Aspekte dabei mir vergegenwärtigen, wenn ich an die Katze denke und für diese verschiedenen Aspekte sind jeweils wieder andere Hirnregionen zuständig. Also man hat das Gefühlsystem, das Sehsystem, das Hörsystem beteiligt, ganz vielfältige, wenn ich jetzt meine Aufmerksamkeit auf einen Aspekt richte, ist das Aufmerksamkeitssystem beteiligt.
Okay, dann frage ich nochmal anders. Dann liegt wahrscheinlich die Lösung sozusagen nur so im Vergleich von. Also ich beobachte Ereignis A und ich beobachte Ereignis B und jetzt versuche ich, die Unterschiede herauszufinden.
Genau, also das ist genau das Prinzip, das du da jetzt ansprichst, das man verwendet, um Gedanken zu identifizieren, indem man die Gehirnaktivität misst.
Genau, da muss man ja Bereiche dann irgendwie unterscheiden. Also da muss man ja schon auch irgendwelche Größenordnungen, die man unterscheidet, weil man ja nicht jedes einzelne Neuron sozusagen unterscheidet, sondern man unterscheidet ja Funktionsgruppen in dem Moment.
Ja, die Auflösungsebene im Moment von solchen Sachen ist durch die Auflösungsebene der Messung bestimmt. Das heißt, die Auflösungsebene, in der die Theorien gebildet werden, sind üblicherweise immer noch die Brotmann-Ariale, aber die Auflösungsebene, in der Informationen kommuniziert werden, das heißt, man zeigt dann ein Bild. Das ist das Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn, das sich einstellt, wenn ich zum Beispiel an eine Katze denke. Und dieses Bild, das ist sozusagen die Ground Truth. Und dieses Bild hat eine Auflösung von zwischen 1 und 3 Millimetern. Mit der Auflösung hat man die Gehirnaktivität gemessen. Und das ist das Ergebnis, das ist das, was man kommuniziert.
Und wenn man noch genauer schaut, dann merkt man unter Umständen noch mehr Unterschiede.
Man würde, wenn man feiner aufgelöst reinschauen könnte überhaupt, wenn man Verfahren dafür hätte, dann würde man sicherlich noch weiter runtergehen können in diese einzelne, wie man das so nennt, Woksele, also diese Volumeneinheiten von 1 bis 3 Millimeter Kantenlänge, die man da misst, würde man noch weiter reinschauen können und würde dann vielleicht Nervenzellen messen können und dann wird sich das Bild quasi noch weiter ausdifferenzieren.
Wäre deine Erwartung, dass das Bild, was man derzeit hat, sich doch noch grundlegend verändern würde, wenn man die Woksele noch kleiner machen würde?
Ich denke, wir würden sehr viel dadurch in Erfahrung bringen. Ich glaube, wir würden aber auch Probleme damit haben, mit den Datenmengen fertig zu werden. Wir haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten mit der Kernspintomographie, obwohl die Kernspintomographie mit 1 bis 3 Millimetern relativ zu den Nervenzellen noch eine sehr grobe Auflösung hat. Also da sind ein paar hunderttausend Nervenzellen können da drin sein in so einem Voxel, also in so einem kleinen Volumeneinheit. Und obwohl wir eine relativ grobe Auflösung haben, haben wir jetzt schon unglaublich viele Daten und es ist immer so eine Diskussion, ob man überhaupt davon profitieren würde, wenn man noch feiner aufgelöste Daten von diesen Netzwerken messen könnte.
So, jetzt muss man, glaube ich, immer so ein bisschen auf die Schlussfolgerungen kommen, die sich denn so bisher eingestellt haben. Also es wird jetzt viel geforscht, man hat ein ziemlich heftiges Gerät, kann sehr tief reinschauen. Es sind Tausende Studien gemacht worden, um zu verstehen, was macht dieses Hirn eigentlich? Ja, da weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, wie ich fragen soll, aber ich meine, was macht denn dieses Hirn eigentlich? Also was treibt uns?
Ja, das Gehirn ist ja erstmal der Träger unseres Geistes, also unserer mentalen Fähigkeiten. Also das ist so, wie ein Gehirn in Silizium funktioniert, so funktioniert das Gehirn in Neuronen, ja, und das ist erstmal der Träger aller unserer Gedanken. Alles, was an geistiger Aktivität in uns drin steckt, ist durch das Gehirn realisiert. Also insofern habe ich immer die Idee, dass man es sich am besten als so eine Trägersubstanz vorstellt. Dadurch ist auch nicht diese Asymmetrie, die man sonst immer sagt, das Gehirn erzeugt die Gedanken. Das klingt immer viel stärker biologisch determiniert, als es eigentlich sein sollte. Wenn man sagt, das Gehirn ist die Trägersubstanz unserer Gedanken, sieht man auch viel stärker die Gleichberechtigung der Gedanken in diesem Zusammenhang. Und das ist erst mal das, was das Gehirn macht. Es realisiert unsere ganzen geistigen Leistungen. Und das tut es, indem es für jeden Gedanken, den ich habe, erst mal ein unterschiedliches Aktivitätsmuster annimmt. Also man kann sich dann die Frage stellen, woran erkennt man denn zum Beispiel die Gedanken, die eine Person hat, indem man eine Messung der Hirnaktivität macht. Das ist zum Beispiel eine der Forschungsrichtungen, die wir machen. Wenn ich jetzt also so ein Bild bekomme von jemandem, der im Kernschmitt-Domographen liegt, kann ich dann anhand von diesem Bild sehen, was diese Person gerade denkt. Das ist quasi eine Gedankenlesemaschine bauen. Und da macht man sich dann zunutze, dass jeder Gedanke, den eine Person hat, ein anderes Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn einstellen lässt. Das heißt also, wenn ich an einen Hund denke, bekomme ich ein bestimmtes Aktivitätsmuster. An eine Katze bekomme ich ein anderes Aktivitätsmuster. Wenn ich an eine Maus denke, bekomme ich noch ein weiteres Aktivitätsmuster. Weil die Gedanken sind ja verschieden. Das muss ja irgendwie durch das Gehirn realisiert werden. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, woher weiß ich denn, welches Aktivitätsmuster das ist, was mit einer Katze, Hund oder Maus zusammengeht. Das weiß ich ja noch nicht. Wenn ich jetzt einfach an irgendeiner x-bliebigen Person die Hirnaktivität messe, weiß ich ja noch gar nicht, was diese Person gerade denkt. Ich muss also irgendwie wissen, wie ich die entschlüsseln kann, diese Hirnaktivität. Und das tut man darüber, dass man mit maschinellen Lernverfahren, also Mustererkennungsverfahren, lernt, die Aktivitätsmuster zuzuordnen. So ähnlich wie in der Fingerabdruckdatenbank, wo man lernt, wie die räumlichen Profile der Verteilung der Furchen auf den Fingerspitzen sind. So ähnlich macht man das auch, dass man einen Computer trainiert, diese Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn zu erkennen. Und dann auf der Basis dieser Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn sagen zu können, das ist das, was diese Person gerade denkt. Dazu muss man es nicht vorher mal gemessen haben. Ich kann ja in der Fingerabdruckkartei auch nicht eine Person finden, wo ich noch nicht vorher die Fingerabdrücke gemessen habe. Und so ist es in der Regel auch, quasi in dieser Messung der Hirnaktivität, ich nur dann den Gedanken zuordnen kann, wenn ich vorher für diese Person gemessen habe, für dieser Gedanke, wenn sich eine Hirnaktivität enttäuscht.
Der Vergleich hinkt natürlich ein bisschen, weil das eine ist natürlich die Identifikation einer Person, das andere ist die Identifikation einer generellen Funktion in einer beliebigen Person. Oder kann man damit auch messen, ob es sich um eine bestimmte Person handelt?
Ja, also die Person kann man natürlich erst mal erkennen an der Hirnstruktur. Jede Person ist noch viel individueller als auf der Basis ihrer Fingerabdrücke. Aber man kann erst mal die Gedanken einer Person dann am besten zuordnen, wenn man gelernt hat, wie die Gedanken in dieser Person gespeichert sind. Und wenn man dann wissen möchte, wie wäre es denn bei einer anderen Person, wo ich diese Messung noch nicht gemacht habe, dann ist man erst mal viel schlechter. Wenn man quasi das gleiche Muster annimmt, man nimmt an, okay, das wird jetzt auch bei der anderen Person funktionieren, das funktioniert ein bisschen, wenn man nicht so gut ist.
Aber so biometrische Erkennung überhaupt der Person als solcher ist?
Das ist gar kein Problem. Anhand der Hirnstruktur, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, vermutlich, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, aber die Hirnstruktur ist unglaublich individuell. Von Person zu Person sehr verschieden. Wenn man verschiedene Gehirne sieht, das sieht niemals eins aus wie das andere.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ähnliche Hirne?
Ja, ich glaube aber, dass die Ähnlichkeit der Hirnstruktur nicht so interessant ist wie die Ähnlichkeit der Hirnfunktion. Die Frage ist nicht, ob das Gehirn oberflächlich ähnlicher aussieht, weil die sich alle immer gar nicht so ähnlich sehen. Sondern die Frage ist, ob die Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn für bestimmte Ähnlichkeiten funktionieren. So wird das Gehirn ähnlich genutzt. Da kann man sich die Frage stellen, ob Menschen, die ähnliche Informationen kodieren, deren Gehirn ähnlich funktioniert, sich ähnlicher sind. Das hat noch niemand untersucht. Aber das wäre eine interessante Fragestellung. Mal zu wissen, wie ist die neuronale Ähnlichkeit mit der psychologischen Ähnlichkeit verbunden?
Kommen solche Leute besser miteinander klar? Oder schlechter miteinander klar?
Genau, genau. Wir machen gerade eine Studie von einem Doktorand von uns, der will jetzt ein Speeddating untersuchen. Wenn jemand Lust hat, daran teilzunehmen, und in Berlin ist, soll er sich gerne melden, er will ein Speeddating-Experiment machen und feststellen, ob Menschen sich eher zusammenbinden, sich füreinander interessieren, eine Bindung aufbauen. Wenn ihre Gehirnaktivität sich stärker synchronisiert, beziehungsweise wenn die Antwort ihres Gehirns auf bestimmte Schlüsselsituationen sehr ähnlich ist. Das ist so das Thema seiner Promotion.
Und wie vergleicht man das dann, ob die sich wirklich mögen?
Man fragt dann hinterher. Das ist die Speeddating-Situation. Man fragt dann hinterher, welche Person man am meisten gemocht hat.
Verstehe. Und dann guckt man, wie die sich in ihren Hirnstrukturen edeln.
In den Aktivitätsmuster. In den Aktivitätsmuster, nicht so sehr in den Strukturen.
Ich lerne das gerade zu unterscheiden. Dauert eine Weile. Na ja, okay, alles klar. Aber das ist ganz neu. Ich habe noch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir vielleicht bei der Funktion des Hirns noch nicht so richtig alles hatten. Ich meine, wir hatten ja so die Neuronen und wir hatten irgendwie, dass die also permanent miteinander kommunizieren und das im Wesentlichen mit Strom. Aber man weiß ja auch, wenn so Drogenwirkungen etc. mit ins Spiel kommen, dass dann Botenstoffe auch eine Rolle spielen. Inwiefern ergänzen die denn jetzt dieses Funktionsbild und kann man das genauso lesen mit den Methoden, die wir besprochen haben?
Ja, also ich bin jetzt keine Experte für Psychopharmakologie. Also da müsste man wirklich mal mit einem Psychopharmakologen sprechen, um sich da die Details zu holen. Aber grob ist es erstmal so, dass an der Stelle, wo eine Nervenzelle die Information an eine andere überträgt, das Ganze nicht elektrisch passiert. Das heißt, dieser Kontaktpunkt ist nicht einfach so, als ob man einen Kabel nimmt mit einem Stecker und den irgendwo reinsteckt und damit quasi elektrisch die Information überträgt, sondern die Information wird dann an dieser Kontaktstelle mit Botenstoffen übertragen, mit sogenannten Neurotransmittern, chemisch übertragen, genau. Das heißt, die Information kommt jetzt quasi an über dieses Kabel, das Axon, kommt jetzt zur nächsten Zelle und an dieser Kontaktstelle werden diese Neurotransmitter ausgeschüttet und diese Neurotransmitter, es gibt einen finstigen Spalt zwischen den Nervenzellen an der Kontaktstelle und da gehen dann diese Botenstoffe durch und auf der nächsten Seite lösen die dann wiederum elektrische Aktivität aus. Der Vorteil, den man davon hat, ist, dass man das Ganze modulieren kann. Das heißt, man kann jetzt, indem man in das Hirnmilieu bestimmte Botenstoffe einbringt, auch noch modulieren, wie die Reaktionen sind, eine sogenannte Synapse. Also die Synapsen ist diese Kontaktstelle von einer Nervenzelle zur nächsten. Da kann man dann tatsächlich modulieren und da spielen dann auch bestimmte chemische oder psychopharmakologische Veränderungen an dieser Stelle rein. Wenn man so etwas einbringt in dieses Hirnmilieu, das dann an dieser Stelle auch entfallen kann.
Das ist auch nicht nur ein Botenstoff, der das jetzt bei allen realisiert?
Nein, es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Botenstoffe. Die ganz wesentliche Unterteilung ist zwischen erregenden und hemmenden Botenstoffen. Es kann also sein, dass eine Zelle die nächste Zelle hemmt. Das ist ein sogenanntes GABA. Dann wird der Neurotransmitter GABA ausgeschüttet. Es gibt dann die Möglichkeit, dass eine Zelle die nächste aktiviert. ZB. Glutamat wäre dann so etwas, wo dann die eine Zelle die nächste aktiviert. Das sind einfach unterschiedliche Substanzen, die dann ausgeschüttet werden. Und dann, je nachdem, die nächste Nervenzelle entweder erregen oder hemmen.
Das kann man auch alles extern zuführen. ZB im chinesischen Restaurant kriegt man eine entsprechende Menge Glutamat hinzugefügt.
Ja, Natriumglutamat, ja. Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun? Es muss ja erstmal durch die Blut-Hirn-Schranke durch. Also man kann ja nicht alles, was man isst, wird dann auch automatisch gleich im Gehirn umgesetzt. Und das ist immer so ein Problem bei der Psychopharmakologie, dass man erst mal Substanzen braucht, die durch die Blut-Hirn-Schranke durch können. Also wenn jetzt man im Gehirn anlangt, dann kann man natürlich in der Blutbahn sein, aber dann kann man immer noch nicht in das lokale Milieu ausdiffundieren. Weil es einfach nochmal so einen Filter davor gibt, der nicht einfach alles reinlässt ins Hirn, was da rumschwimmt, weil das Hirn ist nochmal speziell so. Genau, genau, ja.
Das heißt, das Hirn ist auch wirklich physisch isoliert vom Rest des Körpers. Das ist nochmal so ein ganz eigener...
Ja, zu einem gewissen Teil. Also erst mal ist es natürlich vernetzt mit dem Rest des Körpers. Also wir haben ja, das Gehirn sendet ja Nervenbahnen aus in den ganzen Rest des Körpers und kontrolliert, steuert damit sozusagen ganz viele andere Regionen des Körpers. Also es ist nicht autark. Und es bezieht hier auch wiederum Informationen ein aus ganz vielen Bereichen des Körpers. Der Gehirn kommt ja nicht nur Input von, sagen wir mal, unserem Sehsinn oder unserem Hörsinn, sondern es gibt ja alle möglichen Informationen, die in das Gehirn kommen, auch über den Gesamtzustand des Körpers.
Ja, auch wenn man sich mit einem großen See stößt, muss das ja irgendwie...
Genau, muss ja auch was passieren. Und ich sag jetzt mal Hunger zum Beispiel. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Informationen, die im Gehirn jetzt quasi alle zusammenkommen. Deswegen kann man jetzt nicht direkt sagen, dass das Gehirn isoliert ist.
Aber es ist schon ein Sicherheitsbereich. Es ist schon so besonders bewacht.
Genau. Man möchte halt nicht, dass das Gehirn in einen schlechten Operationszustand reinkommt. Deswegen ist auch zum Beispiel der Glutzuckerspiegel im Gehirn enger überwacht. Und einfach das Gehirn nicht unterzuckern zu lassen zum Beispiel.
Diese Botenstoffe, also es gibt Hämmer und es gibt, was hat es so, Erreger?
Genau.
So als grobe Kategorie. Und davon gibt es dann unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen. Und heißt das, dass so bestimmte Stoffe nur bei bestimmten Neuronen zum Einsatz kommen?
Ja, man realisiert damit einfach verschiedene Netzwerke. Also man kann damit quasi verschieden, also es hängt dann wieder mit der Funktion zusammen. Also bei bestimmten Verschaltungsmustern gibt es dann wiederum, kommen bestimmte Botenstoffe auch zum Einsatz. Und die...
Ich meine, eine Nervenzelle imitiert die immer denselben Botenstoff und da gibt es dann sozusagen nur den ihr zugeordneten oder kann jede mehrere zum Einsatz bringen?
Nein, nein, nein, wir haben verschiedene Netzwerke und diese verschiedenen Netzwerke sind spezialisiert auf bestimmte Arten von Botenstoffen. Es gibt zum Beispiel dopaminerge Zellen und es gibt also einfach verschiedene Arten von Botenstoffsystemen, die wiederum mit verschiedenen Funktionen zusammenhängen.
Was sind da so die Hit-Lister?
Zum Beispiel Dopamin, das kennt man ja. Und das Dopamin ist eine modulatorische Substanz, die die Informationsverarbeitung im präfrontalen Cortex ändert. Es gibt verschiedene Funktionen, die dem zugewiesen werden. Zum Beispiel eine der Funktionen, die dem gerne zugewiesen wird, ist die Information abzuschirmen im präfrontalen Cortex. Zum Beispiel eine Gedächtnisfunktion, dass man dann etwas reinspeichert und das abschirmt. Aber das sind auch viele Sachen, die so sehr im Fluss sind, wo man auch vielleicht alle paar Jahre wieder neue Untertypen entdeckt und dann sich auch zum Teil die Forschung dann auch wieder ein anderes Bild bekommt. Aber das ist jetzt die zelluläre Auflösungsebene des Gehirns. Unsere Forschung ist jetzt überwiegend auf die makroskopische Auflösungsebene des Gehirns ausgerichtet. Da gibt es dann nicht so sehr, also Botenstoffe kann man eigentlich nur, wenn überhaupt, mit positronen Emissions- tomografie messen. Und das dann in der Regel mit Patienten. An gesunden Probanden kann man keine Botenstoffe messen. Wir wissen also erstmal nicht welche. Man kann es sehr grob mit der sogenannten Spektroskopie. Aber das gibt einem, also es ist bis heute noch nicht ein besonders entwickelter Bereich, der Kern mit Tomografie.
Okay, dann quäle ich dich mal nicht weiter mit diesen Mikroauflösungen. Kommen wir mal vielleicht so ein bisschen zum Makrowerk. Aber da ging ja meine Frage eigentlich auch schon ein bisschen hin. So dieses, was macht das Hirn jetzt eigentlich? Also was kann man jetzt sagen? Wie ist das organisiert? Also ich habe echt Schwierigkeiten, jetzt überhaupt einen Ansatzpunkt zu finden. Weil es gibt ja irgendwie auch jetzt nicht so ein Anfang und ein Ende. Sondern das Ganze wirkt ja so permanent. Maximal parallel. Und jede Information, die generiert wird, ist gleichzeitig wieder der Input von sich selbst. Auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise. Es ist ja jetzt kein einfach zu beobachtender Körper. Und trotz alledem gibt es ja ganz offensichtlich da eine wohl definierte Marschroute. Weil wir ja all diese Dinge eben können. Steuern und fühlen und denken und träumen und was für nicht alles noch zu tun. Was für weiträumige Netzwerkstrukturen kann man denn jetzt im Wesentlichen ausmachen? Was tut das Hirn?
Das ist wieder so eine Frage, da wird man keine Antwort darauf finden. Wir können alle möglichen kognitiven Funktionen definieren. Und wir können sagen, wie diese kognitiven Funktionen im Gehirn realisiert sind. Also deswegen, wenn man sagt, was tut das Gehirn? Das Gehirn sind erst einmal 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen, die miteinander interagieren. Wenn ich also verstehen will, wie funktioniert dieses Gehirn, muss ich erst einmal so grob wissen, was für Arten von Funktionen gibt es denn überhaupt?
Ist das so ein bisschen wie so ein Ameisenhaufen?
Ja, ich meine, die Organisationskomplexität des Gehirns ist sicherlich viel größer als die des Ameisenhaufens. Und man findet halt verschiedene Bereiche des Gehirns, die unterschiedliche Funktionen realisieren, die dann auch wieder miteinander überlappend sind. Also es ist keine einfache Geschichte, die man dann finden wird. Und der beste Schlüssel, um zu verstehen, wie das Gehirn funktioniert, ist, dass man sich erstmal die Funktionen anschaut, die das realisiert. Und da ist man dann bei der Psychologie, bei den kogentiven Funktionen. Was gibt es alles an kogentiven Funktionen? Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene kogentive Funktionen. Und ich kann mich, wie gesagt, ich kann wahrnehmen, ich kann mich erinnern, ich kann planen, ich kann, ich hab Gefühle, ich hab, äh, äh, äh, äh, was weiß ich, ich hab auch manchmal Gedächtnisausfälle vielleicht. Diese ganzen Dinge muss man, äh, muss man alle, ähm, äh, erklären durch korrespondierende Hirnnetzwerke. Und da gibt's dann auch entsprechende Unterteilungen. Dann haben wir zum Beispiel Bereiche des Gehirns, die dann eher weit weg sind von der Sensorik. Die kriegen dann also nicht so viel sensorische Informationen. Die sind auch nicht so dicht an der Motorik. Also die können auch nicht so schnell irgendwas machen, dass der Körper sich bewegt. Aber stattdessen haben die mit komplexen Planungsleistungen zu tun. Oder mit der Hemmung von Verhalten. Und das sehr zerspringend präfrontalen Cortex. Und so kann man eine ganze Reihe von verschiedenen Funktionen identifizieren und schaut sich dann an, welche Netzwerke diese Funktionen realisieren. Wenn man jetzt einfach nur das Gehirn hätte, man würde jetzt diese 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen messen, würde man da erstmal gar nicht weiterkommen. Nicht einfach nur das Verhalten der Nervenzellen hätte, ohne zumindest die zusätzliche Hilfe zu haben, zu verstehen, welche Funktionen jetzt gerade der Organismus als Ganzes realisiert. Also ob der jetzt gerade versucht, sich an etwas zu erinnern, oder ob der gerade versucht, den morgigen Tag zu planen, das ist überhaupt erst das, was mir hilft, so Ordnung reinzubringen in dieses ganze Gewimmel der Hirnaktivität.
Jetzt, es fällt sich einmal die ganze Zeit immer dieser Vergleich mit dem Computer aufdrängen. Und ich glaube, es ist relativ klar, dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Vor allem ist ja beim Computer klar, man hat so die Hardware, man hat so die Software, man hat sozusagen das eigentliche Funktionsgebilde, was dann eben von einer höheren Schicht in Bewegung gebracht wird. Kann man so eine Beobachtung im Hirn auch machen, oder passt es auch auf der Ebene nicht?
Ja, also der Vergleich mit dem Computer, es gibt schon Vergleichsaspekte, wo man sagen kann, da sind Computer und Gehirn sich schon ähnlich. Und ich denke, der Bereich, wo man diese Ähnlichkeit sieht, ist, dass beim Computer hat man einfach Chips oder Transistoren, und dann gibt es Leitungsbahnen. Und das ist im Gehirn ganz genauso, wenn man das Gehirn also durchschneidet, sieht man erstmal auf der Oberfläche draußen die sogenannte graue Substanz, die ist ein paar Millimeter dick, und da sitzen die ganzen Nervenzellen drin. Und da gibt es die weiße Substanz, das ist quasi alles, was da drin ist, und das sind einfach nur Kabel, die zwischen den verschiedenen Nervenzellen hin und her laufen. Das sind diese Leitungen, die Kabel, von denen wir vorhin gesprochen haben, die Axone. Und diese, das kann man schon mit einem Computer vergleichen, indem man sagt, man hat jetzt die Chips und hat man quasi die Kabelstränge, die Leitungsbahn, die auf dem Weatherboard jetzt von einem Chip zum nächsten ziehen, das kann man schon damit vergleichen. Also dass es eine gewisse Funktionstrennung gibt zwischen Signalweiterleitung und Informationsverarbeitung. Das gibt es beim Computer und das gibt es auch beim Gehirn. Es gibt aber einen anderen Aspekt, wo man beim Gehirn, wo die Analogie ganz schnell aufhört, und das ist, dass das Gehirn, man kann die Software und die Hardware nicht voneinander trennen. Beim Computer hat man ganz klar, man hat einen Chip, der bestimmte Funktionen realisiert. Und das tut er durch die ganze Lebenszeit des Computers hindurch, der ändert sich nicht. Und dann hat man vielleicht ein Programm irgendwo in einem Ram-Baustein und dieses Programm, oder vielleicht noch ein ROM, wo irgendwie noch irgendwelche festverdrahteten Programme drin stecken, die der Computer braucht im BIOS oder irgendwie sowas. Ich bin da jetzt kein Experte. Aber die Programme sind ganz klar getrennt von der eigentlichen Rechenarchitektur, die die Arbeit erledigt. Und das kann man im Gehirn nicht voneinander trennen. Die Nervenzellen selbst, die die Information verarbeiten, die die Funktionen realisieren, sind auch das, was durch Lernen modifiziert wird. Das heißt, Hardware und Software sind komplett verschmolzen. Und aus genau diesem Grund ist es auch so schwer, Hardware und Software, also quasi die Software, runterzuziehen vom Gehirn. Es wäre schön, wenn man, sage ich jetzt mal, einfach die Software runterladen könnte. Also die Gedankenwelt einer Person runterladen könnte und vielleicht irgendwie für die Nachwelt aufheben könnte oder auf einem anderen Medium realisieren könnte. Und das ist genau das Problem, dass Hardware und Software beim Gehirn komplett verschmolzen sind. Man wüsste auch gar nicht, welchen Aspekt der Hirnaktivität man sich anschauen müsste, wenn man irgendwas runterladen wollen würde. Also da hinkt die Analogie.
Also nicht so wie bei Matrix, wo man dann irgendwann so den Stecker hinten im Kopf hat und dann lädt man sich neues Wissen ein?
Ja, ich finde das ganz spannend. Die Vorstellung, die es in Science-Fiction-Filmen darüber gibt, wie der Mensch sich quasi in ein Computerwelt einkoppeln würde. Da gibt es ja ganz viele verschiedene. Inception ist auch so ein Film.
Bei Tron wird man einfach gescannt.
Genau. Also die Frage ist, wie könnte sowas überhaupt funktionieren? Und das ist gar nicht so klar zu beantworten, weil unsere Gedankenwelt durch das gesamte Gehirn realisiert wird, müsste man eigentlich im Medialfall eine Kontaktstelle haben zu allen denkbaren Nervenzellen. Mit allen 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen müsste man erstmal einen Kontakt haben. Das ist technisch unmöglich. Wenn man jetzt nur so ein paar Kontaktstellen hätte, dann könnte man sicherlich nicht mit der gleichen Immersivität, also mit dem gleichen Eintaucherlebnis, sich jetzt in solche virtuellen Welten einfinden. Und dann müsste natürlich der Computer auch noch wissen, welche Nervenzelle vaskuliert. In der Entwicklung des Gehirns gibt es Selbstorganisationsprozesse. Diese Selbstorganisationsprozesse bedeuten, dass man Karten, die Zuständigkeit einzelner Nervenzellen, in so einem Geflecht von Nervenzellen, die Zuständigkeit wird zum Teil selbstorganisiert gelernt. Deswegen ist es auch von einer Person zur nächsten Person immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich realisiert. So wie die Flecken vielleicht beim Zebra. Das Grundmuster ist gleich, aber es ist immer wieder ein bisschen anders realisiert. Deswegen werde ich die Frage, wenn man da jetzt wirklich mit den ganzen 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen sich koppeln wollen würde, nur mal so hypothetisch nicht, dass das jetzt gehen würde, schon, aber dann müsste man ja überhaupt erst mal wissen, was denn die einzelne Nervenzelle macht. Und das weiß man halt eben nicht. Deswegen ist es gar nicht mal so leicht, etwas ins Gehirn reinzuspielen. Es ist fast noch schwerer, etwas ins Gehirn reinzuspielen und sich vorzustellen, wie das überhaupt möglich sein könnte, als sich vorzustellen, wie man etwas aus dem Gehirn herauslesen könnte. Da gibt es schon Erdtechniken. Aber reinspielen ist sehr schwierig.
Das heißt, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, während man beim Computer so die statische Struktur hat und dann darauf eben so eine veränderbare, aber zum Zeitpunkt des Aufspielens dann auch statische Anweisungsstruktur der Software hat, ist beim Hirn eher so, dass das Hirn sich selbst genau die Struktur selbst baut und sich ja auch laufend verändert. Und dass das Lernen selbst die Struktur selbst ändert. Also ungefähr so würde ich den Computer ein neues Programm beibringen, würde sich quasi die Leiterbahnen irgendwie aufschmelzen und auf neue Arten und Weisen verbinden. Auf einmal werden Verbindungen da, wo sie nicht waren, Chips lösen sich auf und gehen in andere über, etc.
Sehr schön formuliert. Also das wäre die Analogie. Es gibt diesen schönen Ausdruck, man baut das Schiff um, während man damit segelt.
Das sehe ich jetzt im Science-Fiction-Film aber auch nicht so schlecht aus. Könnte man eigentlich durchaus mal...
Ja, vielleicht neue Rechnerarchitekturen, die man sich vorstellen könnte. Ein anderer Aspekt ist natürlich, dass das Gehirn hochgradig parallel arbeitet. Es gibt natürlich die Möglichkeit, Rechner mit vielen Kernen parallel anzusteuern. Aber das ist eigentlich eher die Ausnahme. Die meiste Computer-Software ist doch immer noch sehr seriell, den Jahr geschrieben. Das ist auch etwas, wo sich das Gehirn unterscheidet. Das Gehirn ist assoziativ. Das Gehirn arbeitet nicht seriell, sondern parallel. Ein weiterer Aspekt, den das Gehirn hat, den man beim Computer nicht hat, ist die katastrophale Ausfälle. Dadurch ist eine gewisse Redundanz eingebaut durch das Codierungsformat. Wenn man eine einzelne Nervenzelle verliert, hat man immer noch die Information. Das ist bei einem Computer ein bisschen anders. Wenn der Speicherbereich weg ist, der gerade meine Anweisung codiert, dann ist es katastrophal weg. Das ist beim Gehirn nicht so. Auch wenn man kleinere Schädigungen des Gehirns hat, je nachdem, wo die sind, kann man zum Teil fast gar nichts davon merken, weil viele Funktionen und Repräsentationen auch redundant angelegt sind in ihrem Codierungsformat.
Wie lange leben denn diese Nervenzellen eigentlich? Werden die permanent erneuert?
Ja, die werden nicht permanent erneuert, sondern die hat man ein Leben lang. Das ist im Bereich der individuellen Entwicklungsgeschichte des Gehirns. Dann wird es entwickelt, dann werden wieder einige Synapsen eingestampft. Man kann zum Teil schon neue entwickeln. Im Bereich der Stammzellforschung wird das diskutiert, wie fern es zu einer Genese kommen kann von neuen Nervenzellen. Aber die Nervenzellen hat man erst mal ein Leben lang.
Erst mal müssen sie ja auch immer entstehen. Wenn ich geboren werde, habe ich ja noch nicht alles. Genau.
Wenn man geboren wird, hat man sich schon alle. Also die Nervenzellen hat man dann schon.
Aber man hat nicht die Verbindung dazwischen?
Es gibt ein interessantes Phänomen, das heißt Pruning. Das Lernen muss nicht dadurch stattfinden, dass man neue Synapsen bildet. Sondern das Lernen kann dadurch stattfinden, dass man bestehende Verbindungen auflöst. Also dass man erst mal eine Überversorgung an Verbindungen hat.
Alles ist mit allem verbunden, und dann kappt man das, was man nicht braucht.
Man könnte es so grob zusammenfassen.
Das ist so oder das meint man, dass es vielleicht so ist? Oder ist es die aktuelle Theorie?
Nein, nein, es gibt tatsächlich Entwicklungsphasen, wo man am Anfang tatsächlich mehr Verknüpfungen hat und dann diese Verknüpfungen dann quasi abgebaut werden.
Aber es gibt auch das andere, dass man neue Verbindungen überhaupt erst aufbaut.
Man kann neue Verbindungen schon aufbauen. Nach Hirnläsion ist es ja auch so, dass sich das Gewebe zum Teil wieder regenerieren kann. Aber die Nervenzellen regenerieren sich nicht. Die Nervenzellen sind da, da muss ich das ja auch mal klarmachen. So eine Nervenzelle hat eine unglaublich komplexe Verschaltung mit ganz vielen anderen Nervenzellen. Wenn man da jetzt sagen wollte, wir ziehen dich jetzt ein, stampfen dich jetzt ein und bauen da jetzt mal eine neue Hände, dann müsste man erst mal dieses ganze komplexe Verknüpfungsmuster wieder nachbauen.
Das kann sich nicht so ein weiteres recovern.
Da gibt es auch wieder quasi die zellulären Biologen, die sich mit den Details dieser Netzwerke beschäftigen, wissen da sicherlich auch viel mehr drüber als ich.
Aber das eigentliche Lernen ist dann eigentlich schon dieses, ich knüpfe jetzt auch noch mal hier an und ich liefere meine Information auch noch mal da und dann nicht mehr hin.
Die Kernfrage ist, man kann ja auch, es ist ja keine binäre Anknüpfung, die man hat, wo man also quasi entweder mit einer anderen Nervenzelle verbunden ist oder nicht, sondern ist mit einer gewissen Effizienz diese Verbindung ausgestattet. Das heißt also, ich habe quasi eine Verbindung mit einer anderen Nervenzelle und kann auch die Effizienz dieser Verbindung verbessern. Also ich kann quasi das graduell machen. Wenn ich erstmal eine Verbindung habe, kann ich stärker, mehr oder weniger, mehr oder weniger Effizienz die nächste Zelle aktivieren.
Eine Sache, glaube ich, wo jeder, und mir geht es da nicht anders, schon irgendwie Schwierigkeiten hat, sich das überhaupt vorzustellen, ist so die schiere Masse an Informationen, die man so ablegt im Laufe des Lebens. Es gibt ja auch so Leute, ganz wenige, die nichts vergessen.
Gedächtniskünstlers Leben eines Gedächtniskünstlers von Luria zum Beispiel beschrieben. Jemand, der sich angeblich nichts vergessen hat. Also man wird immer irgendwas vergessen.
Ich hab von so einer Frau in den USA gehört, die wirklich meint, sich an jeden Tag ihres Lebens erinnern zu können.
Ja, aber ich will das gar nicht in Zweifel ziehen. Es gibt ja diese Gedächtniskünstler. Die Frage ist eher, ob man sich wirklich an alles erinnert oder ob man sich an den Großteil erinnert oder ob man sich an ungewöhnlich viel erinnert. Und diese Gedächtniskünstler erinnern sich an ungewöhnlich viel, aber sicherlich nicht an alles. An genau die Abfolge dessen, worauf sie, als sie in ein Zimmer reingekommen sind, in welcher Reihenfolge sie angefangen haben, Dinge mit Aufmerksamkeit zu bedenken und so weiter. Also das wird da auch Gräsen des Ganzen geben. Aber es sind nicht interessante Fälle. Über die Neurowissenschaft kann ich da relativ wenig sagen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel da jetzt bekannt ist in diesem speziellen Bereich der quasi begabten Forschung. Aber das ist natürlich etwas, wo man sehen kann, dass das Vergessen eine gewisse konstruktive Wirkung haben kann. Es gibt quasi die Vorstellung, mehr speichern ist immer gut. Aber es ist auch manchmal ganz gut, um einfach den Überblick zu behalten, dass man viele Details auch vielleicht einfach mal vergisst.
Oder um so traumatische Erlebnisse auch einfach auszublenden.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch immer so eine Diskussion, ob es denn überhaupt möglich ist, traumatische Erlebnisse zu vergessen. Das ist fast schon eine religiöse Diskussion zwischen verschiedenen Bereichen der Psychologie. Ob man jetzt quasi etwas so sehr verdrängt, dass man sich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern kann, ob es wirklich komplett unterdrückt ist oder ob man sich eigentlich nicht doch an die schlimmen Dinge immer besonders gut erinnern kann. Das ist quasi die andere Schule, die das behauptet. Weil wenn jemand etwas komplett vergessen hat, dann kann man ihn ja fragen und dann weiß er es ja nicht mehr. Und es ist die Frage, wie erkennt man denn jetzt, dass diese Person das schon erlebt hat, aber es verdrängt hat? Wie will man das erkennen? Da muss man natürlich mit Aufdeckungsfragen arbeiten. Und das ist ja alles, was sehr stark kritisiert worden ist, auch im Umgang mit Zeugen von sexuellem Missbrauch zum Beispiel. In den 90er-Jahren gab es da ganz viele Diskussionen mit Augenzeugen, Berichte, wo dann einfach irgendwann nicht mehr klar war, was war jetzt wirklich erlebt worden und was war durch die Befragung seitens von Mitarbeitern im Kinderschutzbereich auch quasi durch Suggestionen eingeredet worden. Gar nicht mal bösartig, darum geht es gar nicht.
So als Kollateralschaden.
Ja, aber man merkt vielleicht manchmal gar nicht, wie sehr man auch mit Suggestionen arbeitet. Man kann ja Experimente machen, die ungefähr so funktionieren. Man zeigt jetzt jemandem ein Bild und dann nimmt man es wieder weg. Und dann fragt man zehn Minuten später, war da ein Auto? Ja, nein. Oder man fragt, welche Farbe hatte das Auto? Und dann fragt man zehn Minuten später nochmal nach, ob da ein Auto war. Und die Person, die die Suggestion gekriegt hat, die quasi die Frage, die voran nimmt, dass da ein Auto drin gewesen ist, meint dann auch, sich zu erinnern, dass da ein Auto in dem Bild gewesen ist, in dem ersten. Also es sind ganz subtile Manipulationen, die unser Gedächtnis beeinflussen können. Einfach schon dadurch, dass man annimmt, dass es so oder so gewesen ist, kann man dann schon quasi die Gedächtnisinhalte einpflanzen. Und unser Gedächtnis ist auch nicht so gut, wie man denkt. Ganz im Gegenteil. Auch wir haben starke Illusionen. Es gibt diese schöne Untersuchung zum sogenannten Flashbulb-Memory, also Blitzlichterinnerung, wo man dann Leute fragt, wo waren sie denn, als die Challenger-Katastrophe passierte? Oder wo waren sie denn, als sie vom Kennedy-Mord gehört haben? Wo man dann denkt, das ist so was, so ein Snapshot, quasi so ein Polaroid-Foto-artige Abspeicherung dieser Situation. Und was man früher immer betrachtet hat, war, dass diese Erinnerungen sehr detailreich, also quasi ausgeschmückt sind, dass man sich genau daran erinnert. Da hat man durch detaillierte Forschung festgestellt, dass die Leute sich gar nicht gut daran erinnern, wo sie dann eigentlich gewesen sind. Also häufig sich extrem darin täuschen und ihre Geschichten sich über die Jahre sehr stark verändern.
Aber sie sind zumindest davon überzeugt, dass sie sich gut erinnern können.
Absolut, und das ist natürlich gerade die Gefahr, das ist auch bei Augenzeugenberichten zum Teil die Gefahr, dass dann Menschen denken können und vollkommen überzeugt sind, dass sie sich noch genau erinnern, aber möglicherweise bestimmten Suggestionen oder Gedächtnisveränderungen aufsetzen, die sie selber gar nicht bemerken.
Aber wo geht es denn rein, diese ganzen Dinge? Ich meine zumindest, ich mag viel vergessen, aber abgelegt wurde zumindest für eine Weile doch eine ganze Menge, weil irgendwann habe ich mich ja auch an das mal erinnert, was ich erlebt habe und eine Zeit lang war das für mich präsentes Wissen und dann habe ich es halt vergessen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Wo ist dieses Wissen? Wie speichere ich ein Bild ab? Heißt das, dass dann neue Verschaltungen zwischen meinen Neuronen permanent entstehen durch das und durch mein tägliches Erleben, dass eigentlich die ganze Zeit die permanente Wahrnehmung, die auf mich eintritt, in Form von Internetbild, Ton, was auch immer, permanent meine Hirnstruktur verändert und das ist dann meine Erinnerung? Oder gibt es da nochmal so einen Ram? Gibt es da nochmal so einen Chemiespeicher?
Nee, also es gibt im Gehirn keinen Speicher. Also es gibt die Bereiche, die meine Wahrnehmung codieren, die für meine Wahrnehmung zuständig sind, sind auch die gleichen, mit denen ich dann auch später, wenn ich mich an den See-Eindruck einer Situation erinnere, die daran auch beteiligt sind. Das Ganze wird koordiniert, unter anderem vom Hippokampus. Aber die Erinnerungsspur, wo ist die gespeicherte Erinnerung? Die gespeicherte Erinnerung ist diffus im Gehirn eingeschrieben, und zwar in denjenigen Regionen, die ursprünglich die Informationen auch verarbeitet haben.
Das Werkzeug wird zum Speicher?
Genau, man kann diese verschiedenen Aspekte nicht voneinander trennen. Der Speicher ist wie in einem Hologramm, weil überall das Gleiche ist bei einem Hologramm, sondern ist weiträumig über das Gehirn verteilt. Man hat überall ein bisschen was hingeschrieben. Diese Art der Speicherung macht es auch so schwer, das genau zu lokalisieren. Man hat überall ein bisschen Informationen gespeichert. Deswegen kann man nicht sagen, es gibt eine Region, die man auslesen müsste, wenn man die Erinnerungen einer Person runterladen wollte. Man müsste sich das gesamte Gehirn anschauen.
Der Stimmeindruck, den ich von jemandem habe, ist da, wo ich höre. Der optische Eindruck ist da, wo ich gucke. Und man lässt sich irgendwie erahnen, was für eine Art Modifikation das ist. Mir kommen natürlich diese Informationsdichte, die ich da erinnere, sehr groß vor. Komplexe Sachzusammenhänge, Bilder, Details. Gut, jetzt habe ich 85 Milliarden Neuronen.
Genau, dann ändert man das. Man kann die Verknüpfungsgewichte zwischen den Nerv- und Zellen ändern und damit natürlich Informationen speichern. Man kennt das ja aus diesen technischen Einsätzen der neuronalen Netze. Wenn man ein neuronales Netz trainiert, also im Computer trainiert, zum Beispiel eine bestimmte Erkennungsleistung zu machen, dann tut man das darüber, dass man die Verknüpfungsgewichte zwischen den Nervenzellen ändert, zwischen diesen simulierten Nervenzellen. Dann kann man zu einem Netzwerk Informationen einprägen. So ähnlich stellt man sich das vor, dass das Gehirn das auch macht, dass dann die Verknüpfungsgewichte zwischen den Nervenzellen geändert werden und darüber dann die Informationen gespeichert wird. Man muss dann nicht eine neue Synapse kreieren. Es würde reichen, das Übertragungsgewicht, die Effizienz der Verbindung von einer Nervenzelle zur nächsten zu erhöhen.
Das heißt, man speichert eigentlich so ein bisschen das eigentliche Aufnahmesignal. Dadurch, dass so, wie der Eindruck ankam und wie er dann kommuniziert wurde, dass an den Stellen, wo das kommuniziert wurde, diese Kommunikationsstärke als solche zunimmt. Aber das eben in ganz vielen Neuronen, wodurch sich das ergibt. Das heißt aber auch, dass eigentlich, da ich ja an denselben Stellen auch alle anderen Eindrücke mache, dass ich eigentlich mit jeder neuen Erinnerung zwangsläufig eine andere verdränge oder abschwäche.
Ja, nicht unbedingt. Also inwiefern jetzt der eine Inhalt, den man reinschreibt, in Konkurrenz gerät mit dem anderen, hängt stark davon ab, wie ähnlich der eine und der andere sind. Wenn die sich also verschieden genug sind, hat man da erstmal keine Probleme. Das entspricht ja auch der Erfahrung, dass Dinge, die sich irgendwie alle ähneln, an die kann man sich auch nicht so gut erinnern, wie Dinge, die verschieden sind. Je verschiedener die Dinge sind, desto mehr kann ich es mir merken, kann sie erinnern, kann sie unabhängig voneinander abrufen. Aber im Gedächtnis verwechselt man dann vielleicht auch mal Dinge, die sich einfach hinreichend ähnlich sind. Der Sommerurlaub vor drei Jahren in Italien und der Sommerurlaub vor vier Jahren in Italien, da verwechselt man vielleicht mal, was man da jetzt in dem jeweiligen Urlaub gemacht hat. Die Ähnlichkeit wird dann auch zur Verwechslung. Unter anderem auch deswegen, weil sich der Abruf sehr ähnlich ist.
Erinnern, das ist jetzt wirklich so die Wahrnehmung, das was von außen ankommt und das Abrufen daran. Was ist jetzt mit den anderen Dingen, die wir im Hirn machen? Planen, du hast ja vorhin gesagt, das ist so eine tolle menschliche Eigenschaft, dass wir das so gut können. Was geht denn dann so, ich meine überhaupt so dieses Denken, wenn man einfach nur so sitzt und so denkt. Passiert ja auch schon irgendwas, man will ja immer irgendwas, man will ja immer irgendwas, also wahrscheinlich ruft man die ganze Zeit Erinnerungen ab und kombiniert sie und dann überlegt man, was man damit am besten anstellen kann.
Ja, also ich meine, Planungsleistung muss man erstmal sagen. Menschliche Kultur zeigt natürlich, dass unsere Planungsfähigkeit über das, was Tiere machen können, weit hinausgeht. Wir haben komplexe gesellschaftliche Arbeitsteilungszusammenhänge, die überhaupt nicht möglich wären, wenn Menschen nicht dazu in der Lage wären, ihr eigenes Verhalten sehr stark voraus zu koordinieren und dann auch noch zu koordinieren mit anderen Menschen. Das zeigt einfach, was für eine Komplexität unsere Verhaltensplanung fähig ist. Man weiß ungefähr, welche Bereiche des Gehirns diese Planungsleistungen vollbringen. Man weiß, dass der sogenannte präfrontale Cortex, also ein Bereich des Gehirns, der quasi für höhere Aufgaben, Steuerungsaufgaben zuständig ist, man weiß aber bis heute noch nicht genau, wie diese Planung vonstattengeht. Also wie man das macht, das ist ein ganz interessantes Forschungsgebiet, wo jetzt im Moment gerade viel gearbeitet wird. Eine der Vorstellungen ist, dass man bei Planungsarbeiten, dass man quasi weiter, quasi ist auf der Hierarchie nach oben geht, desto weiter vorne im Gehirn, in diesem präfrontalen Cortex, wird die Information verarbeitet. Also vielleicht meine kleineren Steuerungsbedürfnisse für meinen Tag, wenn ich am Computer sitze, am Rechner sitze und irgendwie einen Brief tippe, das ist vielleicht, kann man quasi die nächste Ebene betrachten, das ist Teil meines Tagesplans, wo ich morgens zur Arbeit gehe, dann nachmittags gehe ich zur Post und abends gehe ich zum Sport, ist da wieder Teil eines komplexen Plans, meines Wochenplans oder meiner Wochenaufteilung, meiner Zeit und so weiter und so fort. Und diese verschiedenen Regulationsebenen, da ist so eine Vorstellung, dass je mehr man quasi nach oben geht, also größere Zeiträume gesehen, quasi komplexere Steuerungsbedürfnisse, desto weiter geht man nach vorne im Gehirn. Das ist so eine der Theorien. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt quasi diesen, es gibt also viel Forschung oder nicht viel Forschung in dem Bereich, aber es gibt mehr Theorien als gute Experimente in diesem Bereich, sagen wir es mal so.
Was ist mit den Gefühlen? Dann fühlt sich auch mal irgendwie gerade gut, schlecht.
Ja, genau. Also gewissen relativ gut, wo welche Regionen des Gehirns der Kodierung von Gefühlen beteiligt sind. Dazu zählt die sogenannte Insel, ein Teil des Neokortex. Dann dazu zählt die Amygdala und der sogenannte orbite frontale Cortex, also die wesentlichen Regionen, die daran beteiligt sind. Und man weiß, dass wenn man ein Gefühl hat, wenn man verschiedene Gefühle unterscheiden möchte, dass dann Aktivität vor allen Dingen in diesen Netzwerken zu verzeichnen ist. Aber natürlich auch das immer weiträumigere Aktivität auch immer zu verzeichnen ist. Also es ist dann auch nicht so, dass nur dieses Netzwerk aktiv ist. Und es geht dann auch immer darüber hinaus. Also grob gesehen kann man sagen, das sind so die Big Player. Und interessant ist natürlich etwas, was man so in den 90er Jahren sehr stark diskutiert hat, ist so der Unterschied zwischen Cold Cognition und Hot Cognition. Das heißt also Cold Cognition ist die Vorstellung, dass man einfach durch eine vollkommen rationale Analyse zum Ergebnis eines Problems kommen kann.
Also kalte Wahrnehmung und warme Wahrnehmung sozusagen.
Ja, oder Erkennung vielleicht, ja. Und die warme Wahrnehmung hat dann die Rolle von Emotionen bei auch Problemlöseprozessen betont. Das Kernproblem ist ja folgendes. Wenn ich zum Beispiel überlege, soll ich jetzt, was weiß ich was, hier in Berlin an der HU oder an der FU studieren? Nimm mal an, jemand ist in dieser Situation. Dann kann man eigentlich die Vor- und die Nachteile aufzählen, der jeweiligen Institution. Aber man hat ja noch keine Bewertung dabei, wie wichtig einem das eine versus das andere ist. Das weiß man ja nicht. Also man weiß dann nicht, wenn ich jetzt, was weiß ich was, die große Hörsäle oder kleine Hörsäle, die wir haben. Ja, oder für das eine muss ich vielleicht nach Dalem fahren. Dafür ist irgendwie die Cafeteria besser oder irgend sowas. Und diese solche Entscheidung zu fällen, gibt es nicht zum einen die Informationsebene, aber selbst wenn ich diese ganzen Informationen habe, weiß ich ja noch gar nicht, wie ich diese Informationen bewerte. Weiß ich ja immer noch nicht, wie wichtig sie mir sind. Das ist halt so eine der Vorstellungen, dass die Intuition quasi die Emotionen mit da reinbringt und dass man halt damit dann die Wichtigkeit, die diese verschiedenen Faktoren haben, dass man die mit da reinrechnen kann.
Das macht man eigentlich nicht mehr im Hirn, das macht man ja mit dem Bauch.
Das ist so die Vorstellung, das Bauchgefühl sitzt ja nicht im Bauch, sondern das Bauchgefühl sitzt auch im Gehirn. Die Liebe sitzt auch nicht im Herzen.
Das ist alles im Hirn.
Alle unsere Erlebnisse sind im Gehirn. Also alles, was wir bewusst erleben, ist im Gehirn. Auch unser Körperschema ist auch alles im Gehirn. Wenn ich meinen Finger angucke und den bewege, dann denke ich vielleicht, ich kann mit meinem Gedanken in meinen Finger reinschlöpfen, aber das findet alles im Gehirn statt. Das Gehirn ist der einzige Ort, den wir kennen, wo bewusstes Denken möglich ist, wo bewusste Erlebnisse möglich sind.
Und Unbewusste?
Ja, es gibt eigentlich eine ganze Reihe von Verarbeitungsprozessen im Gehirn, die uns nicht bewusst sind. Ansonsten würde ich zu jedem Zeitpunkt sagen können, was meine ganzen 85 Milliarden Nervenzellen machen. Das weiß ich ja nicht. Das, was ich bewusst erlebe, ist immer nur eine sehr reduzierte Version von der Komplexität der Prozesse, die tatsächlich im Gehirn ablaufen. Die Schwierigkeit dabei ist, diese unbewussten Prozesse zu messen, weil ich dadurch, dass ich jemanden frage, ob er jetzt gerade bewusst über etwas nachdenkt oder nicht, ja immer seine Aufmerksamkeit darauf richte. Nehmen wir mal das Beispiel mit dem Autofahrer. Jemand sitzt im Auto, unterhält sich angeregt, kommt nach 20 Minuten im Zielort an und sagt, Mensch, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich hierhergekommen bin. Ich habe mich die ganze Zeit so angeregt unterhalten. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich gefahren bin. Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern. Versuchen, zeig, was das Gehirn quasi automatisch, unbewusst möglicherweise sogar erledigen kann, an Aufgaben erledigen kann. Und wenn man ihn jetzt mal zwischendrin fragen würde, dann würde er natürlich wieder anfangen, über das Autofahren nachzudenken. Das ist eine der großen Probleme, wenn man unbewusste Leistungen oder Verarbeitungsprozesse im Gehirn demonstrieren möchte. Das ist eine der großen Prozesse. Man muss ja erst mal wissen, ob die Person gerade bewusst darüber nachdenkt oder nicht. Das muss man ja wissen, wenn man so etwas untersucht.
Und da denken Sie jetzt nicht an einen rosa Infrarot?
Genau, man lenkt dann dadurch, dass man die Probanden befragt, die Aufmerksamkeit und das Bewusstsein auf das, was man eigentlich untersuchen wollte, als unbewusst. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Genau, das ist das Heisenbergsche Problem in der Psychologie.
Trotzdem, also diese Gefühlslage, das Bewusstsein, das Unterbewusstsein, das sind ja auch alles so unglaublich globale Dinge. Also, wie ich mich fühle, hat ja eine Auswirkung auf mein ganzes Denken. Also, so nehme ich das zumindest wahr. Oder so denkt man sich das. Das ist eine Terminologieverwirrung ohne Gleichen, wenn man übers Hirn redet. So was wie, ich fühle mich gut und ich fühle mich schlecht, was mir auch meinen ganzen Antrieb steuert, überhaupt irgendwas zu unternehmen oder nicht. Wie seht ihr das? Das ist ja auch eine sehr weiträumige Auswirkung.
Ja, da müsste man auch wieder mit einem Psychiater sprechen und mit einem Psychotherapeuten sprechen. Also keine Psychotherapie und keine Psychiatrie.
Ja, aber ich meine, lässt sich das sozusagen messen. Kann man eine Depression sehen, wenn man da Kernspinnen...
Also wenn man eine Depression diagnostizieren möchte, dann wäre das Beste, dass man zum Psychotherapeuten oder zu einem Psychiater geht, weil derngleich die klassischen Verhaltenskriterien oder Selbstberichtskriterien, die man da abklopft. Man kann jetzt nicht auf der Basis einer Messung des Gehirns feststellen, ob jemand depressiv ist oder nicht. Zumindest wäre die letzte Bestätigung des Ganzen, dass die Person selber diese klassischen klinischen Kriterien dann angeben würde. Aber es ist zu einem gewissen Grad schon möglich, aus der Hirnaktivität und aus der Hirnstruktur zu erkennen, zu einem gewissen Grad, ob jemand eine Wahrscheinlichkeit hat. Das ist ein Künstler, der dann die diagnostische Zuordnung machen würde, aber ich sag mal, man kann das schon zum Teil im Gehirn erkennen, nur wenn man dann hinterher die endgültige Entscheidung darüber, würde dann immer noch einem Kliniker überlassen werden.
Aber du denkst schon, dass man das sozusagen ablesen könnte, wenn man es nicht mehr genau beobachtet hat.
Ja, ich hab jetzt keine Prozentzahlen im Kopf, wie gut es geht, aber es gibt da Forschung dazu, wie gesagt, automatisierte Diagnostik heißt das Ganze. Man trainiert einen Computer an Beispielen von Hirnstrukturen und Hirnaktivitäten von Gesunden und Depressiven und man guckt dann, ob ein Computer dann diesen Unterschied erkennen kann und das dann richtig zurausnen kann. Da hat es eigentlich alle möglichen Implikationen, aber zurzeit ist es jetzt nicht so weit entwickelt, dass man sich jetzt den Experten sparen könnte.
Was ist denn so mit, wir hatten so dieses Bewusste und Unterbewusste, da denkt man natürlich gleich so an Hypnose. Ist das irgendwie so ein definierter Zustand oder ist das auch alles nur Einbildung?
Na, es ist wieder eins dieser religiösen Themen, sowie die traumatische Verdrängung. Da gibt es natürlich erhebliche Gräben zwischen Leuten, die der Hypnose alles Mögliche an Möglichkeiten zutrauen und den eher skeptischen Leuten wie mir, die sagen würden, also dass die Probanden da vielleicht gut mitspielen und in einen tiefen Entspannungszustand kommen, wo man durch Suggestion und Führung dann auch an bestimmte Dinge rankommen kann, die die Person sonst vielleicht nicht so ohne weiteres erzählen würde, aber dass man damit quasi einen anderen Bewusstseinszustand erforscht, wo man dann, ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen, weg ist und dann der Kontrolle des Hypnotiseurs unterliegt, das halte ich ehrlich gesagt für humbug. Ich will damit nicht sagen, dass es nicht Bühnenzauber und Bühnenhypnose gibt und so was alles und dass viele Menschen mitspielen, dass manche Menschen dann eher mitspielen als andere, aber dass man seinen Willen an der Tür abgibt bei der Hypnose und dann hinterher wieder zurückkriegt, wenn der Hypnotiseur mit den Fingern schnippst, das ist sicherlich nicht der Fall. Da ist dann auch immer eine Bereitschaft dabei, mitzuspielen.
Zumindest gibt es keine Erkenntnisse darüber, dass das Hirn irgendwie so einen Zustand hat, in dem es irgendwie so komplett die Eigenkontrolle aufgibt.
Genau, ich meine, natürlich, wenn man jemanden in einen tiefen Entspannungszustand bringt, und das würde ich die Hypnose auch ansehen, ist natürlich die Hirnaktivität anders als wenn man wach ist und Herr seiner Dinge, Herr seiner Sinne ist. Aber das bedeutet noch lange nicht, dass es sich da um einen ungewöhnlichen Zustand handelt, der eine besondere Kontrolle durch den Hypnotiseur erlauben würde.
Aber was auch ein sehr unbewusster Zustand ist, ist ja Schlafen. Also wenn ich jetzt schlafe, dann weiß ich nicht, also ich würde das jetzt keinen bewussten Zustand nennen. Man ist nicht immer den gerade bewusst los, weil irgendwie man träumt ja auch. Also was passiert denn, wenn der Körper sich ausruht und schläft? Ruht sich das Hirn auch aus? Wird der so irgendwie in so ein Low-Power-Modus gefahren? Verbraucht weniger Energie und tut andere Dinge und macht so Clean-Up?
Ja, also das Gehirn ist die ganze Zeit aktiv, auch nachts beim Schlafen ist das Gehirn aktiv. Und es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt quasi das System runterfährt nachts. Und das nicht nur während der sogenannten REM-Phase, also während man Rapid Eye Movement-Phase, also während man die Augen bewegt und man eigentlich besonders wach träumt, also nicht wach träumt, also Traumerlebnisse hat, sondern auch in der Non-REM-Schlafphase ist das Gehirn aktiv. Und eine der Vorstellungen natürlich, die seit ihr hier dann kursiert haben, ist, dass da die Tagesinhalte verarbeitet werden. Was, glaube ich, zu den letzten Jahren vor allen Dingen aufgekommen ist, ist die Vorstellung, dass Lerninhalte da noch mal konsolidiert werden. Das heißt also, dass bestimmte Dinge, die ich am Tag gelernt habe, auch da noch mal verfestigt werden. Und dafür braucht man wirklich auch Hirnaktivität. Man weiß ja auch, dass solche Sachen darunter leiden, wenn Menschen einen Schlafentzug haben, wie zum Beispiel junge Eltern, dann auch bestimmte Konsolidierungsprozesse vielleicht nicht so eintreten.
Ja, so eine gewisse Rahmdösigkeit. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich schlafe und jetzt keine bewussten Eindrücke mehr habe, weil die Augen sind ja dann auch zu, das heißt, es gibt ja schon ein Abfallen von Eingabe.
Genau.
Man fühlt noch, man spürt, man hat die Temperatur, etc. Aber gucken fällt ja schon mal weg. Und Sprachkommunikation in dem Sinne, weiß ich nicht, ich meine, das kann natürlich jemand mit einem reden, aber man reagiert ja in der Regel nicht da drauf, oder doch?
Genau, die Motorik ist abgekoppelt. Also der entscheidende Unterschied ist nicht so sehr, was ich so erlebe, sondern Input und Output sind abgekoppelt. Also zum Teil kann man noch Umweltereignisse, die man hört, kann man noch mit zum Teil im Traum verarbeiten. Wir kennen das alle, man wacht irgendwie auf und hat irgendwie eine Phase von irgendwas geträumt, dass man im Traum einen Wecker gehört hat und den dann wieder ausgeschaltet hat. Und dann wacht man auf und dann klingelt der Wecker tatsächlich gerade. Wir können also auf auditorische Außenweltreize anscheinend tatsächlich im Traum auch reagieren. Aber im Wesentlichen ist der Input abgekoppelt und die Motorik ist abgeschaltet. Also wir träumen dann davon vielleicht, dass wir uns bewegen können, dass wir durch die Gegend laufen, irgendwas erleben im Traum. Und wir laufen aber dann nicht wirklich durch die Gegend.
Und der Schlafwandler so, der?
Ja, mir ist kein Experiment bekannt, leider, wo man es geschafft hat. Den Schlafwandler während des Schlafandels in einen Kernschwemmendomographen zu bringen.
Aber es gibt Schlafwandler?
Ja, es gibt Schlafwandler. Genau, es gibt Schlafwandler. Was da genau passiert, ich weiß nicht, ob man da was darüber weiß. Das müsste man mal einen Schlafforscher fragen. Das Gebiet der Hirnforschung ist ja dermaßen aufgespaltet und so komplex, dass man sich in der Regel auf dem eigenen Teilgebiet gut auskennt, aber dann von den anderen Bereichen dann auch nicht unbedingt die neuesten Entwicklungen kennt. Da müsste man einfach mal einen Schlafforscher danach fragen. Mit dem kann man sich sicherlich auch zwei Stunden und Tage.
Ich befürchte immer schon bei jeder meiner Frage, dass ich eigentlich immer in vollkommen falsche Genre reingerätsche. Aber was ist mit Intelligenz? Was ist mit, dass ein Hirn kann bessere Leistungen erzielen als andere? Ich meine, es gibt ja offensichtlich Leute, die zu besseren kognitiven, planerischen etc. Fähigkeiten aufgestellt sind als andere. Und es gibt ja auch diesen IQ-Messwert, keine Ahnung, was du davon hältst. Gibt es da eine Erkenntnis, was Intelligenz letztlich ausmacht?
Ja, also ich muss erst mal anfangen, was ist denn Intelligenz überhaupt? Und das kann man natürlich nur auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise definieren. Und so wie es Intelligenztests normalerweise definieren, gibt es eine Reihe von Untertests, was sich verbale Fähigkeiten, dann die Fähigkeit, geometrische Problemlöser-Aufgaben zu lösen, gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Untertests, die man dann da bearbeitet. Und dann mittelt man das halt alles zusammen. Und dann kriegt man halt den IQ. Und der IQ ist standardmäßig definiert, dass der Durchschnitt der Bevölkerung hat 100. Und dann um 15 ist dann die Standardabweichung drumherum. Wir können also sagen, das ist quasi so genormt, dass der Durchschnittsmensch einen IQ von 100 hat, die hängt stark davon ab, welche Aufgaben man da reinbringt. Also wenn man jetzt andere Aufgaben nehmen würde, wären andere Menschen vielleicht besser. Es gibt ja auch diese Diskussion um emotionalen Intelligenzquotienten oder die emotionalen Quotienten, dass man sowas auch mit da einbauen müsste. Man kann natürlich alle möglichen Rechenwerte machen, aber dann gibt es die Vorstellung, also eine alte Diskussion in der Psychologie, wie viel davon jetzt ein allgemeiner Faktor ist in der Intelligenz, also wie viel sozusagen, wenn ich mich besser ausdrücken kann oder besser verbale Probleme lösen kann, ob ich dann auch besser geometrische Probleme lösen kann, wie so Tangram-artige Experimente machen und sowas. Und wie so oft ist so die Antwort so irgendwo in der Mitte, es gibt einen allgemeinen Faktor, aber es gibt auch quasi Differenzen dann von Person zu Person. Und jetzt kann man sich danach suchen. Und was man jetzt zum Beispiel gefunden hat in der Hirnstruktur, ist, dass sich das Bild davon, wie sich die Dicke des Gehirns im Laufe der Entwicklung entwickelt, dass die etwas darüber Auskunft geben kann, wie sich die Intelligenz bei dieser Person entwickelt. Also die Dicke nicht des Gehirns, sondern des Cortex, der kortikalen Schicht. Mist man das quasi mit einem Kernschmettomographen, also diesmal strukturelle Kernschmettomographie, man schaut sich dann die Dicke des Cortex an, also wo die grauen Zellen drin sind, die Nervenzellen.
Das ist das, die Außenhaut?
Genau, genau. Nein, nicht die Außenhaut, sondern es ist die erste Schicht, wo die Nervenzellen, die Zellkörper der Nervenzellen quasi drin sitzen. Und dann kann man da einfach die Dicke messen. Und es ist nicht die Idee, dass dann, wenn das dicker wird, dass dann möglicherweise die Nervenzellen mehr aktiv sind oder irgendwie mehr Verknüpfungen gebildet haben oder irgendwas in diese Richtung. Und dann hat man gesehen, dass dieses Muster der Verdickung und Verdünnung aber auch der cortikalen Dicke, dass die etwas einem darüber sagen kann wie intelligent Mensch. Was es bedeutet, ist natürlich noch eine ganz andere Frage.
Wenn man jetzt von solchen Tests ausgeht wie beim IQ und man hat so konkrete Lösungen, ich meine, das ist bestimmt auch schon mal im Kernspintomographen durchgeführt worden. Wenn man jetzt sagt, hier hat man jemanden mit guten Ergebnissen, hier hat man jemanden mit schlechten Ergebnissen, wobei ich nicht ganz weiß, hat das was mit der Dauer zu tun, wie lange man braucht oder ob man überhaupt darauf kommt?
Wir haben ja aber ganz viel mit solchen Sachen zu tun, die jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt in den Intelligenz messen, so Bestandteil klassischer Intelligenztests sind. Aber wenn Leute im Kernspintomographen liegen und an Experimenten teilnehmen, geht es natürlich auch immer darum, wie gut können sie eine bestimmte Aufgabe lösen. Weil wir wollen ja nicht, dass die vor sich hinschlummern, sondern wir wollen ja gerne, dass die uns quasi, dass die quasi, wir wollen im Gehirn bei der Arbeit zuschauen. Und das kann man natürlich nur, wenn der Proband auch ein bisschen quasi dazu motiviert wird, sich quasi auch quasi mit der Aufgabe zu befassen und eine gute Performance abzuliefern. Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man dann Probanden hat, die das ein bisschen besser können, Probanden hat, die das ein bisschen schlechter können, aber es gibt jetzt nicht so eine ganz eindeutige Zuordnung dazu, dass man sagen kann, das Gehirn ist immer mehr aktiv, wenn sie es ein bisschen besser können. Es gibt nämlich manchmal diese paradoxen Effekte, dass manchmal Leute, die es schlechter können, ihr Gehirn stärker brauchen als Leute, die es nicht, die es besser, Leute, die es schlechter können, ihr Gehirn stärker aktivieren müssen als Leute, die es nicht, die es gut können. Also sie brauchen mehr Energie, würde ich sagen. Es gibt andere Bereiche, wo dann das Gehirn dann stärker aktiv ist, wenn man es dann besser kann. Also es gibt da keine allgemeine Antwort darauf, auf diese Frage. Und so ist es mit EQ-Tests natürlich auch. Ich denke, da wird man noch ein bisschen verstehen müssen, was so die Grundvariablen sind. Du hast ja vorhin danach gefragt, was sind denn die Grundvariablen unseres Denkens? Und da braucht man sicherlich noch mal eine klarere Vorstellung davon, wie denn diese Grundtests im Intelligenztest auch mit den Funktionen des Gehirns, also der Architektur des Gehirns, zusammenhängen.
Also alles noch ein bisschen unklar. Hast du da irgendwie so eine persönliche Theorie, was ein intelligentes Hirn im Wesentlichen qualifiziert?
Ja, ich habe da keine große Theorie dazu. Mein Eindruck ist, dass man, wenn man sich an oberflächlichen Dingen orientiert, man da nicht besonders weit kommt. Zum Beispiel weiß man, dass die Hirngröße relativ wenig mit der Deleganz zu tun hat. Also wenn man jetzt nicht die Extreme nimmt, hat die Hirngröße relativ wenig mit Intelligenz zu tun. Einsteins Gehirn war zum Beispiel unterdurchschnittlich groß. Also die Hirngröße ist es nicht. Es sind zentrale Verknüpfungen. Also ich glaube, das kommt einfach eher darauf an, wie man einen Computer beschreibt, der gut oder schlecht funktioniert, um eine Analogie aus dem Computerbereich zu nehmen, dann kommt es auf viele Dinge an. Unter anderem auch, wie gut die Programme geschrieben sind, die da drauf laufen, wie die Entwicklungsgeschichte ist und so weiter, wie gut das System gepflegt ist. Das kommt auf ganz viele verschiedene Faktoren an. Ich glaube, dass man deswegen...
Das heißt, Intelligenz ist vielleicht, ich sage jetzt mal bewusst vielleicht, vielleicht auch eine Frage der Entwicklung des Menschen und wie so das Hirn genutzt, benutzt wurde über die Zeit, wie die Eindrücke waren.
Ja, das weiß man schon lange aus der Psychologie, dass die Intelligenzentwicklung durch angereicherte Umwelten stark befördert wird. Dass die Entwicklungsgeschichte eine starke Rolle dabei spielt, ist ganz klar. Aber es gibt natürlich auch einen genetischen Faktor und den kann man auch nicht leugnen. Es spielt beides eine Rolle.
Aber wie sich dieser genetische Faktor dann letztlich in diesem Gehirn niederschlägt, das ist noch unklar.
Ja, also wie gesagt, da muss man wieder jemanden fragen, der das als spezielles Forschungsgebiet hat. Und der wird einem da sicherlich auch wieder mehr darüber sagen können.
Du hast ja gesagt, nachts ist das Hirn ist auch aktiv. Und je nachdem, was ich tue, ist mal das eine, mal das andere aktiv. Wie viel des Hirns liegt denn so brach? Benutzen wir immer nur so einen Teil davon? So immer, was man so gerade braucht? Und vielleicht liegt auch eine Menge rum? Oder ist eigentlich irgendwie am laufenden Meter alles da, nur je nachdem, was ich halt gerade mache, eben nur für einen kurzen Moment der eine Teil, für einen kurzen Moment der andere Teil. Aber im Wesentlichen kommt alles irgendwie zum Zuge.
Genau, also das Letzte ist auf jeden Fall, gibt es diese Vorstellung, wir nutzen nur 10% unserer Hirnaktivität. Das ist also totaler Quatsch. Man weiß erst mal, dass die, wir haben ja vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, die Hirnfunktionen sehr stark aufgegliedert sind. Also jeder Teil des Gehirns macht eine etwas andere Aufgabe. Wenn wir da jetzt was rausnehmen, würde es in vielen Bereichen des Gehirns sehr stark auffallen. Wir würden also irgendwas nicht mehr machen können. Wir könnten vielleicht nicht mehr unsere Aufmerksamkeit irgendwo hinlenken. Wir könnten nicht mehr sehen, wir könnten nicht mehr hören, wir könnten uns nicht mehr erinnern und so weiter und so fort. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, wir nutzen nur 10% unseres Gehirns, dann würde man ja auch sagen, da kann man die anderen 90% auch wegschneiden. Das kann man auf jeden Fall nicht durch die starke Arbeitsteilung des Gehirns. Aber es ist auch so, wenn man dem Gehirn bei Aufgaben zuschaut, im Kernschmitt-Domographen kann man das ganz klar sehen, es sind immer weiträumige Netzwerke des Gehirns aktiv. Es ist also nie nur so, dass man sieht, dass eine bestimmte Funktion nur an einem klitzekleinen Teil des Gehirns stattfindet. Es sind immer weiträumig große Netzwerke des Gehirns an jeder Arbeit auch beteiligt.
Also ist alles wichtig?
Es ist nicht alles gleich wichtig. Das ist ja auch eine der interessanten Dinge, dass es Regionen des Gehirns gibt, da kann man also Schäden haben und man merkt das eigentlich gar nicht so richtig. Man merkt das dann erst, wenn man so differenzierte neuropsychologische Testverfahren verwendet und dann herauskitzelt, dass dann doch irgendwo bestimmte Defizite sich befinden, zum Beispiel vielleicht bei der Fähigkeit, seinen Alltag zu koordinieren. Man merkt das dann nicht mehr. Man unterhält sich mit jemandem, hat ein normales Gespräch, denkt, der ist doch irgendwie fit beieinander und so weiter. Und dann stellt man fest, der ist fast unfähig darin oder hat nicht die Fähigkeit mehr, seinen Alltag zu koordinieren. Das sind dann so Funktionen, die man leicht übersehen kann. Und die muss man dann halt erst mal abbilden. Und dann sieht man dann nicht unbedingt immer sofort, wenn es einen Ausfall in dem Bereich des Gehirns gibt, was dann der Teil ist, der dann dementsprechend auch ausgefallen ist. Aber es ist schon so, dass man zu jedem Teil des Gehirns auch irgendeinen Defizit finden wird, was dann die Person hat, die unter dieser Lesion leidet.
Jetzt haben wir schon häufig so den Fall, dass ich immer gefragt habe, wie geht denn das? Und du sagst immer, ja, kann man nicht so genau sagen. Gibt es denn Sachen, kann man denn überhaupt irgendwas genau sagen? Ich meine, es gibt ja zahlreiche Beispiele, wo Leute mit ihrem EEG-System irgendwelche Dinge steuern, Roboterarme etc. Und es gibt ja auch schon so, was ist das? Armprothesen, Handsteuerung etc. Wie fern ist man in der Lage, jetzt wirklich herauszufinden, was der Mensch gerade denkt, was er gerade will, was er versucht zu tun in dem Moment, wo die Nerven fehlen und man versucht, das irgendwie maschinell abzunehmen?
Ja, es ist nicht ein superspannendes Forschungsgebiet, wo man dann auch wirklich mal in die Praxis gehen kann mit der Hirnforschung. Das ist also die Frage nach sogenannten Brain-Reading, heißt es auf der einen Seite. Also was kann man aus der Hirnaktivität über eine Person, die Gedanken einer Person in Erfahrung bringen und dann auch sogenannte Gehirn-Computerschnittstellen? Wie fern kann man dann damit wiederum irgendwelche Geräte steuern? Und das quasi das Brain-Reading selbst, also das allgemeine aufgestellte Thema, man kann es populärwissenschaftlich vielleicht ganz plakativ als Gedankenlesen bezeichnen, ist etwas, was sich in den letzten Jahren schon sehr stark weiterentwickelt hat, wo dann so die Grundlagen gelegt wurden, wo man dann festgestellt hat, man kann das Computer darauf trainieren, aus der Hirnaktivität zu einem gewissen Grad zu erkennen, was jemand gerade denkt, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn man vorher gelernt hat, wie die Gedanken in der Hirnaktivität codiert sind, also wenn man es vorher einfach dem Computer beigebracht hat, wenn man Beispiele der Hirnaktivität dieser Person hatte, während er zum Beispiel eine Hund, Katze, Maus gedacht hat.
Das ist aber erforderlich auch dafür.
Ja, das ist dafür erforderlich.
Also ohne so ein Training geht es gar nicht.
Ohne Training geht es gar nicht. Und man hat da jetzt in den letzten Jahren sehr viel erreicht, aber es ist natürlich immer noch etwas, was man jetzt nicht mit so einer Science-Fiction-Vorstellung in Verbindung bringen kann.
Na gut, aber was hat man denn erreicht? Also was geht?
Ja, man kann Bilder, die eine Person sieht, auslesen. Man kann Bilder, die sich eine Person nur vorstellt, auslesen.
Wie man kann die Bilder auslesen?
Naja, nehmen wir mal an, jemand stellt sich jetzt eins von verschiedenen Bildern vor. Und entweder Tiere, Häuser, Gesichter, also irgendwie verschiedene Kategorien, Landschaften. Und wir wollen jetzt wissen, woran hat die Person gerade gedacht. Und zwar stellt sich das einfach nur lebendig vor, aber sieht kein Bild.
Aber man weiß, aus welchen Optionen ausgewählt wird.
Genau, genau, genau. Und dann kann man tatsächlich aus der Hirnaktivität dekodieren, also auslesen, wenn man vorher gelernt hat, wie die Aktivitätsmuster sind für diese Person bei diesen verschiedenen Vorstellungen, welches Bild eine Person gerade denkt. Man kann das zu einem gewissen Teil auch machen, ohne dass man jetzt genau das gleiche Bild gelernt hat. Und zwar indem man sich Ähnlichkeitsbeziehungen zwischen den Bildern zunutze macht. Zum Beispiel kann man sich zunutze machen, dass ein Motorrad sowas ist, ein bisschen wie ein Auto, aber auch ein bisschen wie ein Fahrrad. Und wenn man weiß, wie das Aktivitätsmuster für ein Auto ist und für ein Fahrrad, dann weiß man auch, wie das Aktivitätsmuster für ein Motorrad ist.
Aber wieder, man muss das Aktivitätsmuster von dieser speziellen Person bei Autos wissen.
Genau, genau, genau, und es gibt Wege, mit denen man das so ein bisschen auflockern kann, diese Erfordernis, aber so grobem kann man das tatsächlich so sagen. Und jetzt kommt also die Frage, kann man da möglicherweise weitergehen als nur bildliche Inhalte, also visuelle Vorstellungen? Und das ist auch tatsächlich so, man kann bestimmte Erinnerungen abrufen, man kann die Gefühle, die eine Person gerade hat, zu einem gewissen Teil darin erkennen, man kann erkennen, welche Pläne eine Person hat, aber wiederum immer nur in diesen Situationen, wo man weiß, wie die Aktivitätsmuster aussehen für die verschiedenen Optionen, die gerade bedacht werden. Und das ist so die Einschränkung. Aber für viele technische Anwendungen, da kommt man dann zu den Gehirn- und Computerschnittstellen, braucht man gar nicht dieses Detail. Man braucht gar nicht unbedingt, wenn man jetzt eine Maschine steuern möchte, mit Gedankenkraft. Das heißt, man stellt sich vor, was die Maschine machen soll und der Computer erkennt dann in der Gehirnaktivität, was man sich wünscht. Dann gibt es ja gar nicht so viele Optionen, sondern es reicht ja schon, ein paar Alternativen erkennen zu können. Das machen sich die sogenannten Leute, die an den sogenannten Gehirn- und Computerschnittstellen arbeiten, die machen sich das zunutze und machen das üblicherweise mit EEG, mit Elektroenzephylogramm, weil man damit eine schnelle Steuerung ermöglichen kann. Auch wenn die Aktivität des Gehirns nicht räumlich so gut aufgelöst werden kann, nutzt man dann so Vorstellungen wie zum Beispiel, ich bewege meine rechte Hand und dann will ich, dass so ein Cursor sich links rum bewegt und ich stelle mir vor, ich bewege meine linke Hand und dann bewegt sich ein Cursor, das wäre jetzt falsch rum. Also ich stecke und bewege meine rechte Hand, bewegt sich ein Cursor nach rechts, ich stelle mir vor, meine linke Hand bewegt sich, dann bewegt sich der Cursor nach links und so können wir zum Beispiel Buchstaben auswählen. Also so auf diese Art und Weise kann man sich das vorstellen, einen Computerschnitt stellen, die einem dann ermöglichen, quasi mit so einer Gedankenhilfskrücke, dann die zu buchstabieren.
Aber das geht jetzt nur deshalb, weil linke Hand und rechte Hand an komplett anderen Orten gearbeitet werden.
Genau, die rechte Hand wird in der linken Hemisphäre gesteuert und die linke Hand in der rechten Hemisphäre gesteuert. Genau. Und deswegen kann man daraus dann diese Information ziehen. Und man kann dann mit reiner Vorstellung der Bewegung, der Computer nimmt das dann auf und erkennt dann diese Aktivität und dann kann man damit einen Computer steuern. Gibt es hier in der TU zum Beispiel Arbeitsgruppen, es gibt in Freiburg Arbeitsgruppen, in Tübingen, gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Arbeitsgruppen in Deutschland, die das wirklich auf Weltniveau machen und damit so einige interessante Sachen gemacht haben, hier in Berlin zum Beispiel. Dann schaffen sie es dann, so einen Flipper zu steuern mit der Gedankenkraft. Da kann man dann einfach nur, indem man sich dann vorstellt, welcher von diesen Flippern sich bewegen soll, links oder rechts, kann man dann den Flipper steuern.
Nach Training, oder?
Ja, das Besondere bei denen ist dann, dass der Computer lernt, sich dem Menschen anzupassen und der Mensch nicht so viel lernen muss, sich dem Computer anzupassen. Das ist so deren Idee, also du sagst gerade Training, trainiert wird da vor allen Dingen der Computer, nicht so sehr der Mensch.
Das heißt, der Computer versucht sozusagen herauszufinden, ob, also ich beobachte ja die Situation und ich kann ja, ich habe ja auch eine Reaktion da drauf, ob jetzt die Maschine das getan hat, was ich möchte. Und wenn man in der Lage ist, dieses Belohnungsmoment auszuwerten, dann könnte ja wirklich auch ein selbstlernendes System dabei entstehen, also auf der Computerseite.
Also das macht man jetzt nicht, weil das zu kompliziert wäre. Man macht es wirklich so, dass man ungefähr eine Idee davon hat, wie bei einem Menschen, wenn er sich die rechte Hand bewegend vorstellt oder die linke Hand sich bewegend vorstellt, wie das Hirnaktivitätsmuster aussieht. Und man baut das quasi so darüber auf. Also diese Komplexität, dass man dann wirklich genau wüsste, ach, jetzt haben wir gerade was gemacht, was er nicht wollte, und das müssen wir jetzt erkennen können. Und dann irgendwie nochmal zurückgehen, uns nochmal ändern.
Würde es nicht vielleicht reichen, wenn ich einfach so Enttäuschung erkenne und Begeisterung erkenne und das unterscheide?
Ja, aber dazu müsste man das im EEG erkennen können. Ich weiß nicht, ob das EEG die ausreichende Auflösung hat, um diese subtilen emotionalen Unterschiede erkennen zu können. Und zwar muss man es ja realtime machen, also sozusagen in Echtzeit schnell erkennen können. Das heißt, es ist nicht irgendwas, das man in gemittelten EEG-Signalen über 1000 Durchgänge sieht, sondern man muss es ja wirklich in jedem einzelnen EEG zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt perfekt auslesen können, ob jemand gerade enttäuscht ist oder sich freut darüber, dass es funktioniert hat. Da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das EEG da genügend diese beiden Befindlichkeiten auflösen kann oder nicht.
Es gibt auch diese Lügen-Detektoren. Ich meine, das sind jetzt, was ich weiß, in der Vergangenheit nicht ans Hirn rangegangen, sondern es waren ja andere Quellen, die dort angezapft wurden. Was wurde da gemacht? Gibt es so einen ähnlichen Ansatz auch für Hirnauswertungen, dass man irgendwie Leute beim Lügen erwischt?
Ja, es gibt auch seit Altes her, die Vorstellung, dass es toll wäre, wenn man feststellen könnte, ob jemand lügt oder nicht. Und da gab es dann im 20. Jahrhundert die Entwicklung des sogenannten Lügendetektors. Das sind diese Polygraphen. Die heißen Polygraphen, weil sie verschiedene Messungen oder Aspekte peripherer Erregung messen. Also zum Beispiel Herzrate, Atemfrequenz, Blutdruck und dann vor allen Dingen den Hautwiderstand. Also wenn man schwitzt, dann ändert sich der Hautwiderstand. Und das misst man dann damit. Und damit kann man tatsächlich relativ gut, wenn die Untersuchungsperson nicht trainiert ist, das zu überlisten, kann man damit tatsächlich relativ gut erkennen. Wenn zum Beispiel jemand eine Zahl von 1 bis 10 denkt, im Praktikumsexperiment, kann man damit relativ gut das Ganze erkennen. Es gibt ja auch solche einfachen Baukästen, oder so Kästen, die man kaufen kann, mit denen man es zu Hause mal so durchspielen kann. Es gibt so einen Kosmos, drei Fragezeichen, einen Lügendetektor, da schließt man sich einfach an zwei Finger an. Dann gibt es einen Pfeifen, was höher wird, wenn man quasi den Hautwiderstand abnimmt. Dann kann man damit relativ gut schon mit rumspielen und erkennen, ob jemand jetzt die Wahrheit sagt oder nicht. Man merkt zumindest, wo sensible Themen sind. Man spricht dann zehn Themen an und dann das Ganze in die Höhe schnellt, weiß man. Das ist ein sensibles Thema, das funktioniert recht gut. Es ist erstaunlich, wie gut das funktioniert. Aber das Problem ist, dass man diese Geräte überlisten kann. Das heißt, man kann lernen, wie man diese Geräte überlistet, und zwar weil man seine Erregung kontrollieren kann. Man kann vor allen Dingen seine Erregung künstlich steigern und damit auch quasi das Ganze verzerren. So war die Idee möglicherweise, wenn wir nicht die peripherale Erregung messen, sondern dem Gehirn direkt bei der Lüge zuschauen, können wir besser erkennen, ob jemand gerade lügt oder nicht. Das funktioniert zu einem Grad im Labor. Da weiß man, wenn man einfache Laborlügen nimmt, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen hart, aber man meint damit, dass man jemandem z.B. eine Spielkarte zeigt und dann sagt, wenn ich die dir jetzt gleich zeige, dann sag bitte, dass du sie vorher nicht gesehen hast. Und für solche Art von Lügen hat man schon gezeigt, dass es recht gut funktioniert. So Trefferquoten 80, 90 Prozent. Aber was man halt nicht weiß, ist, ob das wirklich in reellen Situationen funktioniert. Wenn jemand gerade verdächtigt wird, einer Tat verdächtigt wird, wo es ja auch um viel geht, wo die Leute sehr aufgeregt sind, wo viel auf dem Spiel steht, dass in diesen Situationen, ob das da auch funktioniert, darüber weiß man relativ wenig. Und deswegen ist es etwas, das quasi in Erwicklung begriffen ist, aber nicht, dass man das jetzt als fertiges Produkt schon haben könnte. Aber wenn man so was bauen wollen würde, wenn man das auch ethisch in Ordnung betrachtet und es auch rechtlich in Ordnung wäre, dann wäre der Weg, wie man da vorgehen würde, sicherlich besser, dass man mit der Kernschmettermografie vorgeht, dass man einfach die Erregung misst. Das ist sicherlich nicht so gut.
Das heißt, technisch ginge eigentlich schon eine Menge, man macht es aber vielleicht noch nicht?
Nee, es ist eher so, dass man auch für alle Anwendungen zeigen muss, dass sie nicht nur im Labor funktionieren, sondern dass sie auch wirklich in der Welt funktionieren. Und gerade bei Lügendetektoren möchte man sich natürlich ganz besonders sicher sein, dass es richtig funktioniert.
Aber ist das überhaupt so ein Forschungsbereich, der so wünschenswert ist?
Genau, da kann man natürlich dann drüber spekulieren. Also gerade Lügendetektion entfacht wirklich interessante Diskussionen und da reagiert auch jeder anders drauf. Man hat ja erst mal so das Gefühl beim Lügendetektor, das ist ja schrecklich, da überlistet man einen Menschen, liest was gegen seinen Willen aus. Man muss ja schon sagen, dass so ein Lügendetektor ja auch die Möglichkeit hat, jemanden aus dem Gefängnis freizubringen, nämlich dann, wenn man zeigt, dass er nicht gelogen hat. Nehmen wir an, das Ding würde perfekt funktionieren. Das muss man annehmen. Nehmen wir mal an, es funktioniert. Also es gibt mich leicht immer die Vorstellung, dass man nämlich die Zweifel an der Technik mit dem ethischen Zweifel durcheinander wirft. Also die eine Frage, die man sich stellen muss, ist, funktioniert das Ding? Was ist, wenn das Ding funktioniert? Was sind die ethischen Dimensionen? Und dann kann man sich auch noch fragen, kann denn so ein Ding überhaupt funktionieren? Das ist ja die zweite Frage. Man nehme mal an, es würde funktionieren, dann dürfte man das dann benutzen. Ich meine, man hat damit dann tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, wenn man unschuldig ist und sich in so einem Test unterzieht, dann auch aus dem Gefängnis freizukommen. Man könnte das jetzt bösartig so formulieren, dass wenn man den Lügendetektor nicht will, dass man damit die Rechte des Schuldigen höher einstuft als die Rechte des Unschuldigen, seine Unschuld zu beweisen. Und egal, wie man sich da entscheidet, ich will gar nicht sagen, dass die Entscheidung leicht ist, aber egal, wie man sich da entscheidet, man soll sich zumindest zugestehen, dass es nicht einfach so eine einfache Gesinnung ist, die man da abspult, sondern dass man, egal ob man sich dafür oder dagegen entscheidet, das zu benutzen, man einer Gruppe von Personen quasi eine gewisse Last auferlegt. Ich empfehle dem einen, dass möglicherweise etwas gemacht wird, was rausgefunden wird, was er nicht gerne möchte. Aber dem anderen im Zweifelsfall nimmt man dann auch die Möglichkeit, seine Unschuld zu belegen. Man muss sich da halt verorten. Aber dann hat auch beide Aspekte berücksichtigt. Es ist leicht gesagt, man will es nicht. Aber dann soll man sich mal vor jemanden hinstellen, der fleht, dass er unschuldig ist und gerne sich so einem Detektor unterziehen möchte. Und dann sagt man, du musst jetzt im Gefängnis bleiben, weil ich finde es jetzt auch einfach nicht in Ordnung, dass man solche Detektortests verbedutzt. Man soll sich einfach nur die Konsequenzen dessen klarmachen, was man da fordert.
Diese möglichen ethischen Implikationen scheinen mir recht vielseitig zu sein, wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass das mit der Hirnforschung noch weitergeht. Und es geht ja wahrscheinlich weiter. Es gab jetzt durch diese Kernspindengeschichte eine unglaubliche Beschleunigung. Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, in der menschlichen Hirnforschung.
Genau, in der menschlichen Hirnforschung. Ich weiß nicht, ob noch andere technische Durchbrüche anstehen. Das weiß man ja nie so ganz genau, aber wir haben ja schon gesprochen, dass leistungsfähige Systeme die Messgeschwindigkeit erhöhen können, etc. oder auch die Genauigkeit. Einerseits würde ich gerne wissen, wie schätzt du das ein? Wie ist da so diese Ackselration in diesem Forschungsbereich? Gibt es da so Low-Hanging-Fruits, die demnächst gepflückt werden? Und inwiefern verstärkt das eben dann auch diese ethische Bedeutung dieser Forschung als solchen?
Ich glaube, die Low-Hanging-Fruits sind schon im Wesentlichen gepflückt worden. Das sind die neuronalen Korrelate der Religiosität und die neuronalen Korrelate des menschlichen Geschlechtsorgans und die neuronalen Korrelate romantischer Liebe. Da würde ich sagen, das sind die Low-Hanging-Fruits.
Neurologische Korrelate der Religiosität?
Neuronalen Korrelate der Religiosität. Was passiert im Gehirn von jemandem, der religiös ist, anders als bei jemandem, der nicht religiös ist oder gerade religiöse Erlebnisse hat?
Was weiß man?
Ja, da gibt es Unterschiede. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, welche Unterschiede, weil das jetzt nicht etwas ist, was mich besonders interessiert. Aber das sind halt Low-Hanging-Fruit. Das sind halt so die großen Fragen, wo man dann mal im Gehirn nachgeschaut hat. Ich würde jetzt schon sagen, dass es in den letzten Jahren eine Ackselration gegeben hat. Ich glaube aber, dass das Feld jetzt auf so einem Bereich der Normalwissenschaft sich befindet. Weil es gibt viele Zentren, wo Kernschwindforschung gemacht wird, wo auch sehr professionell gemacht wird. Das Gebiet hat sich in viele Unterfragen aufgeteilt, die jetzt untersucht werden. Also die meisten Gruppen spezialisieren sich auf eine oder zwei dieser Fragestellungen. Und das hat sich jetzt zu einem ganz normalen Forschungsgebiet entwickelt. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir dann in zehn Jahren doppelt so viele Kernschwindforschungen wieder haben werden als heute. Zumindest nicht für die neurowissenschaftliche, neuroimagingen Grundlagenforschung. Dafür ist das Ganze auch zu teuer, muss man sagen. So ein Kernschwindhomograph kostet auch 2 Millionen Euro ungefähr. Und kostet allein schon an Wartung pro Jahr so 150.000 Euro. Das ist schon viel Geld, was man da bezahlt, um so ein Gerät am Laufen zu halten. Aber deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass man jetzt noch viel, viel mehr Geld in den Bereich reinpumpen wird. Aber es ist jetzt eine gute Versorgung da, über Deutschland gesehen. Und ich würde sagen, wir befinden uns in einer Phase, wo die Forschung einfach Normalität erreicht und einfach jetzt mehr und mehr an diesen einzelnen Fragen gearbeitet wird.
Und gibt es irgendeinen Durchbruch, der so ansteht? Ich meine, das Higgs-Boson, das ist jetzt gerade gefunden worden. Was ist denn so das Higgs-Boson der Hirnforschung?
Ist das das Bewusstseins-Boson oder sowas?
Ja, halt so eine Verständnis-Ebene, die man gerne erreichen würde. Irgendeinen Schlüssel, von dem man glaubt, dass man vielleicht auch kurz davor ist, oder vielleicht ist er auch noch ein bisschen weiter weg, dass man den findet, um einfach so ein besseres Grundverständnis zu haben. Weil das scheint mir ja dann auch in gewisser Hinsicht noch alles sehr vage zu sein.
Ja, also man kann jetzt natürlich nicht erwarten, dass man, wie man immer so schön sagt, die komplexeste Struktur des menschlichen Universums, was wirklich Quatsch ist, dass das Gehirn das wäre, dass man so eine komplexe Struktur, dass man die nach 20 Jahren Forschung schon komplett verstanden hätte. Das ist wirklich vor allen Dingen nicht unter den Schwierigkeiten, mit denen dieses Forschungsgebiet sich bewegt, nämlich vor allen Dingen, dass man nicht gut messen kann, weil man ja nicht in das Gehirn reingucken kann richtig. Man muss also sich mit dem Indirekten bemühen. Die Fragen, die für Forscher interessant sind, sind nicht immer die, die für die Bevölkerung interessant sind. Wenn man verstehen möchte, wie das Gehirn funktioniert, stellt man sich da schlussendlich die Frage, was macht diese Hirnregion jetzt? Dann gibt es viele Theorien und manchmal Durchbrüche, weil man zeigt, dass sich das nicht gegenseitig ausschließt bei verschiedenen Interpretationen. Oder man zeigt, dass die eine Theorie nicht stimmt, und jetzt stimmt nur die andere Theorie. Das ist nicht alles interessant. Die großen Themen, die für Leute außerhalb der Forschung interessant sind, sind zum einen das Thema Bewusstsein. Das interessiert Leute immer. Wie kann es sein, dass Materie auf einmal so etwas wie Bewusstsein entwickelt? Das ist eine große Frage. Eine andere Frage sind die Gehirn- und Computerschnittstellen. Das finden Menschen auch faszinierend. Willensfreiheit ist auch so ein Thema. Kann man etwas über Willensfreiheit aussagen aus der Hirnforschung?
Im Sinne von was für ein Wille, dass man selbst entscheidet oder entscheidet wird?
Man verfängt sich dann ganz schnell in sprachliche Kapriolen. Aber im Grunde genommen, dass man selbst sein Schicksal entscheidet, dass man die Entscheidung selber fällt und frei ist, diese Entscheidung in eine oder andere Richtung zu beeinflussen. Dass wir quasi nicht auf dem Beifahrersitz unseres Lebens sitzen, sondern dass wir auf dem Fahrersitz sitzen. Und dass wir dann aber auch das sozusagen von Sekunde zu Sekunde machen, was wir wollen. Und dass wir aber auch frei sind, das zu wollen, was wir wollen. Wie man das vielleicht formulieren könnte. Also, dass das, was wir wollen, nicht schon von vornherein durch vorherige Hirnprozesse oder physikalische Prozesse vorgegeben ist.
Oder irgendeine Art Schicksals-Gen.
Genau, genau. Und diese Fragen sind natürlich auch welche, wo man sagen kann, da tut sich jetzt einiges in dem Bereich, in der Erforschung von Vorhersagbarkeit menschlichen Verhaltens und inwiefern das so unseren Intuitionen darüber, wie wir selber uns entscheiden, widerspricht. Und ein weiteres Thema ist natürlich die klinischen Anwendungen. Das heißt also, die Frage, können wir möglicherweise Krankheiten jetzt besser erkennen, indem wir intelligentere Software loslassen auf die Bilder, die wir mit dem Kernschmied Domografen gemessen haben? Das sind so die anderen Clustern-Fragen. Und ich würde sagen, in diesen ganzen Bereichen ist so einiges passiert in den letzten Jahren. Im Bereich Bewusstsein. Man hat ja vorher überhaupt nicht gewusst, wie sich die einzelnen Gedanken, die ein Mensch hat, im Gehirn widerspiegeln. Das wusste man nicht. Tatsächlich ist das so, dass jeder Gedanke, den man hat, ein anderes Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn entspricht. Das hat man ja vorher vielleicht vermutet, aber gezeigt worden ist das erst durch die Kernspintomographie. Und dass wir aus der Hirnaktivität unsere Entscheidungen vorhersagen können, ist auch etwas, was man erst seit den 80er Jahren so richtig gewusst hat aus der Hirnforschung.
Man kann sie vorhersagen?
Ja, zu einem gewissen Grad kann man freie Entscheidungen die Menschen machen, also wenn man das Gefühl hat, ich könnte jetzt das ein oder andere machen, man versucht das jetzt aus dem Gehirn vorhersagen, immerhin einfachen Laborexperimenten, da geht es ja immer darum, welche Taste man drückt oder welches Bild man wählt oder sowas, dass man dann die Wahl schon vorhersagen kann, bevor eine Person das Gefühl hat, dass er sich jetzt schon entschieden hat. Und solche Forschung ist in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren auch gemacht worden, wird jetzt auch noch mehr gemacht. Und die Forschung zum Thema, ich sage jetzt mal, klinische Anwendungen, gibt es wirklich etliche Möglichkeiten. Es ist auch viel passiert in den letzten Jahren. Gerade im Bereich, was wir jetzt auch machen, unter anderem ist so Automatisierung der Diagnostik von MR-Bildern. Also inwiefern kann man mit Software da noch weiterkommen, als man jetzt vielleicht mit dem Blick auf das MR-Bild dann kommen kann?
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, wieso das Hirnbild aussieht von Leuten, die Podcasts hören. Vielleicht im Vergleich zu Leuten, die gerade Fernsehen gucken. Solche Medienbeobachtungen gibt es da sicherlich auch.
Wir haben letztes Jahr tatsächlich jemanden in den Tomografen getan und haben für die Weihnachtskarte der Humboldt-Universität jemanden ins Gänne getan und ihn an Weihnachten denken lassen. Und da sieht man dann, dass Weihnachten anscheinend etwas ist, wo diese Person sehr intensive schöne Gedanken verbracht hat, weil es waren nämlich ganz breite Bereiche des Gehirns, die exklusive von Netzwerken für Gefühle waren auch aktiv.
Wow, richtig ausgesucht sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Und inwiefern hat sich das auf dieser Weihnachtskarte niedergeschlagen?
Ja, man konnte das Aktivitätsmuster auf der Weihnachtskarte sehen. Ach so, das war sozusagen das Bild auf der Weihnachtskarte.
Aber jetzt so Leute beim Fernsehen zu schauen, man sagt ja immer so, auch gerade im Vergleich mit Computeraktivität, so spricht man immer gerne von Lean-forward- und Lean-back-Aktivität. Also wenn man sich mit dem Internet beschäftigt und dann diesen ganzen Katzen-Input auf sich einrieseln lässt, dann sei man irgendwie aktiver, als wenn man jetzt quasi Fernsehen schaut, sich zurücklehnt und dann alles nur so auf sich einprasseln lässt. Ist das irgendwie eine haltbare Vorstellung oder ist das Unfug?
Man braucht nicht für jede Theorie, die das Verhalten des Menschen beschreibt, einen Hirnforscher, der sagt, dass diese Theorie richtig ist oder falsch. Die meisten Dinge, die das menschliche Alltagsverhalten angehen, können wir viel besser mit Psychologie als mit Hirnforschung erklären. Ganz einfach, wenn ich wissen möchte, was du jetzt heute Nachmittag machen wirst, habe ich zwei Optionen. Ich kann dich entweder in den Kernschwindomographen tun oder ich kann dich fragen. Ich glaube, es wird für mich einfacher sein, herauszufinden, was du tun wirst, wenn ich dich frage und nicht, wenn ich dich in den Kernschwindomographen tue. Das gilt nicht für viele Bereiche. Ich bin Hirnforscher und arbeite an der Schnittstelle zwischen Psychologie und Hirnforschung. Ich muss ganz klar sagen, dass die Hirnforschung für viele Alltagsphänomene in der Psychologie oder auch Kulturwissenschaften, wo man immer versucht wird, eine Brücke zu schlagen in die Hirnforschung, erst mal gar nicht so viel zu sagen hat. Man wird dann immer alles Mögliche gefragt. Man kann dann nebulöse Antworten abgeben. Die Leute sind immer nicht damit zufrieden. Oder man erzählt einfach irgendeinen Unsinn. Das passiert auch viel. Aber viele dieser Dinge wissen wir einfach noch nicht. Wir wissen, ob auf irgendeinem Trabanten von Proxima Centauri die Menschen grüne oder rote Hüte aufhaben. Das wissen wir auch nicht. Es gibt viele Bereiche, wo wir nichts dazu sagen können. Das, was du gerade genannt hast, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das ein Forschungsprogramm wäre, dem ich jetzt verschreiben würde, zu versuchen, jeden denkbaren Aspekt menschlichen Verhaltensgleich im Thromographen zu untersuchen. Ich würde sagen, man sollte einen Grund haben, weshalb man wissen möchte, was das im Gehirn ausmacht. Wenn man den Grund nicht hat, hilft es einem auch erst mal nicht.
Der Grund wäre, ob man in irgendeiner Form feststellen kann.
Ob ein Lernen stattfindet. Dazu braucht man auch keinen Kernschwindthomographen. Ich bin Psychologe und Neurewissenschaftler, mache viel Kernschwindforschung. Wenn ich wissen will, ob jemand lernt oder nicht, schaue ich nicht ins Gehirn, sondern mache ein Lernexperiment und schaue, ob die Person z.B. mehr gelernt hat hinterher. Man sollte nicht immer meinen, dass dadurch, dass man eine vermeintlich objektivere Messung der Hirnaktivität hat, dass man damit auch einen besseren Zugriff auf diese ganzen kognitiven Prozesse hat, hat man eigentlich nicht. Also in so einem Fall, wenn mich sowas interessieren würde, würde ich ein psychologisches Experiment machen, einfach gucken, ob die Person sich hinterher an mehr oder weniger erinnert.
Aber ich könnte mich zumindest in den Tomographen reinlegen und an Podcast denken und dann mal schauen, ob das so ähnlich ist wie bei anderen Leuten bei Weihnachten.
Das könnte man vielleicht noch machen, ja.
So John, haben wir noch einen wichtigen Aspekt auf der Strecke bleiben lassen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind schon ziemlich enzyklopädisch vorgegangen und haben schon fast alles gestreift.
Super, dann können wir es ja jetzt auch zu Ende bringen. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung zum Hirn. Und vielen Dank hier fürs Zuhören. Das war es, CRE 195. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald, bis zum nächsten Mal.